what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into the Sinestro Corps war
aftermath this is really kind of like an
epilogue slash prologue or pre lute and
the reason why is because we're most
writers and for those of you guys who
are new to comics most writers will
usually write like a crossover event or
some huge story arc and then they'll
stop and they'll just do like some small
x story or something like that there's
something that doesn't really tie into
anything and it's just kind of there
what geoff johns did for the whole
entirety of Green Lantern is one story
arc the conclusion of a story arc would
lead into the beginning of another story
arc and so this basically goes into
blackest night because remember blackest
night is the whole idea of like these
emerging Lantern cores and so on in this
great big huge war and you know all
those different things and so it was
cool for what it was but it was
basically this great big huge conflict
and so a lot of the different a lot of
the things that we're gonna see which we
now in the time we start blackest night
here in the next hello maybe month or so
a couple months these things will all
basically go into the event of the
blackest night story itself so what this
does is this picks up again with the
aftermath of Sinestro Corps war and in
the last video when we have done that
Sinestro Corps war we had talked about
how it was really the first major
emergence of the yellow lanterns the
first major emergence of Sinestro
forming his own Lantern Corps and I
remember where the Green Lantern's
basically derived their power from the
will aspect of the emotional spectrum
which is to say the ability to overcome
fear the Sinestro Corps derives their
power from fear and so long as there's
fear in the universe so long as there's
a singular being that experiences fear
or is afraid of something then the
Sinestro Corps will always have power
because again they derive their power
from the emotional spectrum just this
infinite source of emotion as long as
there is a being alive in the universe
there will be different forms of
emotions and so again with this whole
idea what we know is that the Sinestro
Corps rings are still going out and
seeking hosts they're still trying to
find people who could be viable
candidates to become members of the
Sinestro Corps and that's really one of
the basis or one of the biggest ideas of
this is that Sinestro set it up so that
should he be defeated the Corps will
continue to grow and so the idea is that
while this is happening we actually pick
up with Kyle Rayner and Guy Gardner now
remember Kyle Rayner and Guy Gardner is
part of the Green Lantern Corps do their
own thing for the most part but the
Green Lantern Corps line of stories ran
side-by-side with the main Green Lantern
stories in the sense of the Green
Lantern Court is focused on the other
core members with the other members
outside of Hal Jordan were basically
doing and the funny thing about this is
this basically guy gardner and kyle
rayner taking off and intending to live
on OA and then guy gardner wanting to
open a bar and it's kind of a funny
scenario because remember ah these
characters come from their own
backgrounds they come from their own
Heritage's their own stories and for the
most part they've all lost a lot of
different things Kyle Rayner more so
than most Kyle Rainer's girlfriends have
all been killed you know he lost his
mother to a parasite that was basically
a member of the Sinestro Corps
you know they've all lost different
things and so leaving planet Earth and
taking up residence on OA serves two
purposes the first is that within the
confines of the Green Lantern mythos it
gives Kyle Rader and Guy Gardner their
own stories their own adventures they
can go out on and do their own thing but
the other half of this is that it
actually sets the stage for future
events later on with regards to why it
is that they're in space as opposed to
Hal Jordan who's spending some of his
time on earth so again it's really set
in the stage for a lot of the things
that we will see later on down the line
when it comes to the Green Lantern
mythos now at this point we pick up with
mangal who is the son of Mongol which is
kind of weird
the first Mongol or as is usually
referred to Mongol one it's basically
like this pre-crisis on Infinite Earths
character that served the purpose of
just being a major foe of Superman
the idea though was that with this
version of Mongol basically Mongol - as
a lot of people call him he made his
emergence in 1995 with the showcase line
of stories I think it was and I want to
say that showcase stories in the mid-90s
were basically stories that were
designed to literally showcase different
villains and heroes and someone and so
forth but the idea is that the original
Mongol had helped to destroy ko City
which set in motion the idea of Hal
Jordan be you know being possessed by
parallax and then becoming a villain and
so on and so forth ah what Mongol to did
is he basically followed up with his
father's grand schemes of trying to
either defeat the Justice League or
defeat Superman or something along those
lines but he basically became a villain
now his big claim to fame was having a
helping hand in Superman you know
basically being prepared for the
invasion of imperiex and imperiex's of
course basically DC's version of
Galactus I mean there's really no way to
say it I mean that's pretty much what he
was but the idea is that this flight a
few instances here and there when Mongol
has helped out Superman they basically
become unwilling allies due to a common
enemy that was stronger than both of
them individually for the most part
Mongol is just all
it's been a bad guy and so what ended up
happening here at least one is up taking
place here is that Mangal is bestowed
with the yellow lantern ring now
remember this makes sense because when
it comes to the yellow Lantern rings
they're designed to instill fear and we
saw during the Sinestro Corps war that
like anti-monitor and hank henshaw
cyborg superman
at superboy-prime these various
individuals had basically been imbued
with a yellow Lantern ring because of
the fact they were able to you know
instill so much fear in individual
people Mongol is much the same way the
difference here is that he actually has
kind of an ace up his sleeve a really
cool really cool hat trick that actually
works really well for the purpose that
he serves now again Jimmy back to Cal
Raider and in Guy Gardner with the whole
idea of this story humor is kind of an
important aspect of the Green Lantern
mythos especially with what's coming
later on down the line because things
are gonna get really really dark no pun
intended
when blackest night rolls around things
will get really dark like it'll be it'll
be really kind of crazy but again for
these guys it's a matter of just kind of
trying to make a way for themselves you
know trying to make their own little
home you know home away from home and
taking up residence on OA now remember
this is not unprecedented there are
people who simply just reside on OA
Kilowog for example resides on OA salak
resides on OA these different members of
the the Green Lantern mythos of course
Kilowog basically being the drill
sergeant for the Green Lantern Corps and
cilok being the voice of the guardians
of the universe it makes sense that they
would resign on OA
buffer guy gardner and kyle rayner they
can really serve or really have the best
use when they're on OA and the reason
for this is because of the fact to
remember with regards to the Green
Lantern's the most part earth is the
only planet that really has like four
different Green Lantern's you've got
Kyle Rayner you've got John Stewart
you've got Guy Gardner and you've got
Hal Jordan you don't need four you
really only need two and so again we
have John Stewart and Hal Jordan back on
earth and we've got Guy Gardner and Kyle
Rayner you know out in space now the
other half of this is remember Mongol is
as intelligent as he is powerful and
that's one of the things that makes him
so dangerous is because he is so capable
and so where some individuals would have
you know would have received a yellow
lantern ring and then would have
immediately just like jumped out into
the fray and sort of fighting Green
Lantern's or something along those lines
Mongol takes a far different approach
instead he basically has a Lantern ring
spend ninety six hours giving him all
the information to the Lantern ring
knows
so over the course of the 72-hour window
Mangal had learned about the origin of
the sinestro rings he learned about the
history of Sinestro himself he learned
about the Green Lantern's he learned
about the blackest night prophecy he'd
learned all these different things
basically everything we've covered up to
this point he was given all that
information within within you know
really like 96 hours or 72 72 hours
wherever the case may be and so the
result is that the guardians of the
universe begin to realize that all these
different Sinestro Corps rings are
basically taking off to the Vega system
and the result is that they begin
calling back together all these
different members of the Green Lantern
Corps now for those of you guys who have
read ahead please do not spoil anything
about the Vega system because I know
what you're thinking do not spoil
anything about the Vega system but what
I will say is there's actually a reason
why the Green Lantern's are not supposed
to go to the Vega system it's actually a
really cool basis behind that but the
funny thing about this is that they're
actually instructed to do so now again
we'll get into that once we get into
like the whole you know pre Leda
blackest night and different things like
that
but the idea here is that for the
guardians of the universe while there
have been treaties and so on that have
been struck over the course of their
existence with different races and
groups that exist across the universe
occasionally the guardians of the
universe will violate those treaties and
the reason for that is because the
threat is just that credible and so
there's two things going on here the
first is that these Sinestro Corps rings
are disappearing to the far side of the
universe and to some individuals who are
being given Sinestro Corps rings are
just dying all of a sudden and nobody
knows why but what we end up doing is we
transition back to and what we end
up finding out here is that Mangal
himself is basically traveling around to
these different individuals who have men
who have been given Sinestro Corps rings
and offers them two options the first is
to either serve Mangal or the second is
to die and a lot of them just refuse
they simply refuse to serve Mangal
because remember the Sinestro Corps
rings bond themselves to what are
basically bullies and so if you're a
person that's been more or less
dominating a slow local village or a
small territory or something along those
lines and then suddenly a semester war
ring appears to you what you're gonna do
what you do best you're just gonna start
bullying people I mean if somebody else
comes along and says you work for me now
well of course you're gonna resist that
the difference here is that we have a
guy who's basically on par with Superman
in a lot of ways who's now been given a
Sinestro Corps ring and so these average
bad guys
these average bullies who have dominated
these small little towns or something
like that while the yellow lantern ring
does give them a whole host of abilities
they have neither the brains nor the the
forethought to be able to use them
effectively and they're easily dominated
by Mangala so the result is that he's
been going around killing these
different Sinestro Corps members and
then taking their rings now what this
does is it basically picks up with the
idea of these different individuals who
are being sent out in groups for the
purpose of tracking down these rings and
what it is is happening these people now
also remember soda yacht is now ion and
of course if you missed the last video
soda meowth was his character who is
basically introduced as a what-if
scenario like what if Superman got a
Green Lantern ring because soda Ma'at
descends from a group that are basically
called daksa mites but they are a branch
off of traditional Kryptonians and so
when exposed to a Yellow Sun suddenly
sodam yacht has all the powers of
Superman combined with a with a Green
Lantern ring now the reason why he's
Iying on in the distinction between ion
and a regular Lantern is that sodam
yacht is basically imbued with pure
willpower with the ion entity and of
course the ion entity is a physical
manifestation of the emotion of
willpower so again that's how all this
stuff really kind of comes together and
we'll see that more over the course of
the Green Lantern mythos that of course
parallax the entity that represents fear
that you know again ion is the entity
that represents will and will see things
like the bowl which is the entity that
represents your rage for the Red Lantern
cores and so on and so forth but the
fact remains here that with ion and
ERISA I think it is that are basically
traveling to you know these different
lantern locations and so on and so forth
the other members of the Lantern Corps
are coming across these basically like
these giant body parts limbs and so on
that belonged to just different members
of the Sinestro Corps who were defeated
who were dismembered so on and so forth
only for us to find out Mangal is
captured of ryssia and M so team yacht
and is basically bestowed upon them
these black mercy plants now remember
these black mercy plants or what it is
that makes Mongols such a dangerous foe
and differentiates him from the other
members of you know really the semester
or really any other villain that exists
out there in the realm of DC Comics and
the reason why I say this is because you
remember the black mercy plants as we
talked about in our DC rebirth video
about Trinity basically were bonded to a
host and in turn that host would enter
this kind of dream state they would
basically experience this whole this
whole illusion
no real idea of what was going on around
them and so the result of this is that
we actually end up finding out that with
a ryssia and with with sodam yacht being
taken away that normally it's supposed
to be this kind of happy experience you
go through these dreams and you have
these incredible experiences you
basically live out this almost perfect
life but instead or Ischia and so dumb
yacht
are experiencing absolute nightmares and
so again this is kind of a cool moment
because what this does is it basically
comes back and it goes to the spaces
behind the mercy plan it's its origin
how it all comes together so on and so
forth and so what the other Green
Lantern's are able to jump in you know
and rescue so dumb yacht and rescue or
risk yet again it's basically this idea
that there's like this mother mercy more
or less I guess this black mercy prime
so to speak is giving birth to all these
different plants that Mongols been using
and so what we end up finding out here
is that we're Mongols going through and
again basically taking all these black
mercy seedlings firing them you know
into the universe for the purpose of
just more or less taking people over
that he's essentially gone through and
modified or at least he's uh benefiting
from these modified uh black mercy
plants in the sense that the black mercy
plants were they're supposed to instill
people with you know happy experiences
and instead are forcing them to
experience a massive amount of fear the
overarching goal of mongol is to
basically force everybody in the
universe to feel fear and in turn
empower himself with his virtually
unrivaled level of power that nobody
else could begin to grasp and so the
result is that where the Green Lantern's
go through and they start freeing sodam
yacht and so on and so forth that the
back a black mercy plant basically
speaks directly to them the mother mercy
plant basically says that originally it
was designed for the purpose of making
death and easy passing that those beings
who experienced death getting ready to
pass over they would basically be imbued
with these plants and they wouldn't
experience the horrific turning the you
know the horrific circumstances under
their own death meaning they wouldn't
suffer pain and different things like
that instead they would basically pass
on with no real impact on what it is it
was happening to them instead what ended
up happening is the first mongrel to
come along and grab these black mercy
plants and then basically started
screwing with them and sort of modifying
them and turning into the turn them into
something that could be used for evil
and so the result is that he intends to
again basically blanket the universe and
fear and empower himself now the reason
why this story matters so much and the
reason why this is such an important
aspect is because again much like the
stories that we saw were you know you
like Hal Jordan most-wanted kind of this
one-off story that existed out there by
themselves what this also does is it
basically lays the groundwork for the
rise of the star sapphires because
remember the star sapphires are
basically the lantern cores that deal
with love they believe love is an
extreme thing we had talked about how
Carol fares to be true had been
transformed into a star sapphire and
then she was eventually freed from its
control this is gonna see them come back
and it's gonna see them being one of the
other Lantern cores that are starting to
rise to prominence and so again it's
these small little things that are
written into this story is these small
little moments where we basically have
this great big huge event that doesn't
really seem to tie into anything and
then it's just this little tidbit much
like we saw with our previous Lantern
videos you know where it was basically
the Justice League fighting alongside
the Green Lantern against some force and
then suddenly a Sinestro Corps ring
suddenly appears to Bruce Wayne and says
you know look you know Bruce Wayne you
had the ability to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and then
eventually does kind of abandons him you
know after realizing he had used a Green
Lantern ring but the fact remains here
that what the Green Lantern's able to
overcome these black mercy plants and
effectively defeating uh this
leads to his character does kind of
being kept in stasis and being kept on
the back burner and the reason why is
because once we start to get into the
whole element of blackest night and
different things like that that he'll
actually make a return that he'll
actually end up coming back and the
result is that he'll play a more
significant role in the different
stories that we see leading into
blackest night and so on and so forth
now the other half of this is the again
you know mother mercy plan herself in
the sense that she's actually inducted
into the Green Lantern Corps because of
the fact that she has the ability to
lean to both sides where the black mercy
plants have the ability to force people
to experience utter fear and at the same
time give people the ability to overcome
fear she's basically given a choice
either she can choose a yellow lantern
wing or she can choose a Green Lantern
ring and then the result is that she
ends up choosing a Green Lantern ring
and joining the Green Lantern Corps but
again this is really the end of this
story I mean it's there's not a whole
lot here not a great big huge set of
events you know a villain that was
that's obscure to most people who don't
recall a book Scott gets a yellow
Lantern ring for a little while and then
is ultimately defeated but again it's
these moments it's these small little
panels these small little segments these
stories that don't seem wildly
interesting that become important later
on down the line
okay so getting into sins of the Star
Sapphire this is actually the first of
three I believe it's three pre ludes to
blackest night the next one is rage of
the Red Lanterns and then the one after
that is Agent Orange Larfleeze man let
me tell you something dear Larfleeze is
so Opie it's not even funny to be that
guy is do that guy's ridiculous I mean
there's man but uh yeah like sons of the
Star Sapphire is interesting because
again when it comes to these pre lewd
stories it's like these small little
tidbits they kind of get thrown in here
and there and really one of the most
important characters that will really go
into blackest night proper is actually a
guy named Sarah Kant least I think
that's how you pronounce his name
it's sa a or ek regardless uh the story
initially picks up with this guy and the
reason why is because we actually join
with this kind of funeral ceremony for
Green Lantern's who have died in battle
and this is actually really really cool
because it shows us what happens
whenever they perish now keep in mind
there are some Green Lantern's that die
and they never recover their corpses and
so as far as I'm able to tell this
ceremony is never held for corpse that
can't be recovered but for those
lanterns who do die in battle they're
given this very you know honorable thing
in the sense that they're basically kind
of stowed alongside all these other
lanterns who perished in conflict and
their story will be recorded in the book
of OA as one of the many instances when
the Green Lantern's were able to achieve
a great goal because remember for those
of you guys who were just now joining us
we're coming out of the Sinestro Corps
war and so of course that covered the
story where a thousand estro basically
formed his own Lantern Corps and led to
a massive war with the Green Lantern's
that resulted in the guardians of the
universe rewriting the book of OA to
allow the Green Lantern's to kill both
members of the Sinestro Corps as well as
anybody who is an enemy of the Green
Lantern's and so again that was a huge
change because it was something that we
had never seen before that with regards
to Sark himself uh his introduction
comes by way of not really interrupting
this funeral service so much as
partaking of it and basically being met
by the arrival of the caretaker himself
basically the guy who was sort of in
charge of all these different you know
funeral services and so on and Sarek
basically reveals that he has the
telepathic ability to communicate with
the dead and this is why I say this is
so important for blackest night because
as we know with blackest night it's the
resurrection of the Dead it's one of the
reasons why I've timed a lot of this
Green Lantern stuff so that blackest
night will begin shortly before October
and then run all the
way through into Halloween I thought I'd
be kind of cool to do that to do like
Green Lantern blackest night every
Sunday all throughout October I thought
it'd be kind of a cool little thing but
the fact remains here that with Sarek
his presence here is really one of
intrigue and mystery more so than
anything else because remember lanterns
don't usually display a power like this
Green Lantern rings complement the
existing powers of you know whatever
being gets a Green Lantern ring but
there haven't really been any instances
when a lantern crops up and says well I
can talk to the dead because now it
becomes a questionable thing now the
other half of this is what's going on
with regards to Kyle Rayner and Guy
Gardner because remember after the
events of Sinestro Corps war their idea
was if they wanted to open a bar which
is actually pretty cool it's a pretty
cool thing just kind of open a bar on OA
but what they end up doing is talking
about the whole idea of like Mongol and
so on and so forth Mongol being a guy
who had basically attained us several
yellow lantern rings but had been handed
over to the black mercy plants to
basically be consumed to quite literally
be physically digested now that's one of
the reasons why we cover that story
because going into things like this
they'll touch back on that and I wanted
to be able at the very least just kind
of say hey look here's what that video
is it's in the Green Lantern playlist
you're welcome to check it out what we
end up finding out is that Mongol has
basically escaped his captivity and so
what that means is that now we have a
guy who in a lot of ways is on par with
Superman in terms of his strength and so
on that has five Sinestro Corps rings so
it's kind of crazy in terms of the power
that he possesses but he actually won't
play a very big role here again this is
sins of the star sapphires and so this
is designed to focus more on the Star
Sapphire cores and the Green Lantern
more so than anything else but the cool
thing about this is that it also hinted
the idea that someone is traveling
around and basically killing off all of
the you know the various parents that
belong to members of the of the Green
Lantern Corps and again this is kind of
a big deal because despite the fact that
thousand Estero was defeated and the the
Sinestro Corps was defeated
they weren't destroyed in their entirety
they're all still very much alive and
the Rings are still going out in
pursuing new recruits for the Sinestro
Corps and so with the idea of someone
traveling around and killing the parents
of recruits who are part of the Green
Lantern Corps this presents a very
dangerous situation and the reason for
this is because of the fact that with
them fearing for the lives of their
parents the fact that the Sinestro Corps
is rooted in fear means that they could
easily be pulled away from the Green
Lantern's inducted in the Sinestro Corps
and
the sinestro course numbers but of
course what we ended up doing is we
basically pick up with CEREC after the
fact that all these different eyes had
has kind of been dropped down onto these
members of the Green Lantern Corps when
they learned their loved ones were being
killed and Saric basically is able to go
through the the memories so to speak
where the very least speak to the dead
through these eyes and then in turn gain
the identity of the person who's doing
this now again this is where the plot
begins to thicken a little bit and the
reason for that is because of the fact
that once the Green Lantern's are able
to sort out who it is that's committing
these actions the question now becomes
who are these guys going to be the other
half of this is that because of the fact
that so many of these new recruits have
basically lost their parents because
they're not really forged in the fires
of battle and therefore don't really
have the willpower necessary to overcome
virtually any and all fear and the fact
that they are so susceptible to the
Sinestro Corps they're stripped of their
Green Lantern rings and they're
basically thrown in isolation now again
this is one of the big failings of the
Green Lantern Corps and that's one of
the things that we're gonna see at the
you know once we get towards the
conclusion of this story but Before we
jump into that we actually jump in with
a character named ice now normally we
wouldn't really jump into this too much
just because of the fact that she's here
for a little bit she talks to guy
Gardner for a little while the two of
them think about moving in and then
that's it but ice actually gives us a
chance to sort of talk about this
background with Guy Gardner because guy
gardner is a character that we haven't
really discussed too much we really
haven't had a reason to outside of
whatever it is that he's doing in any
particular story that goes on but guy
gardner really has his rise and
popularity came by way of Justice League
International but the idea of Justice
League International was to basically
take superheroes who couldn't normally
sell their own comics throw them onto a
team have them led by Batman in order to
boost the team's popularity and then
sell comics and it performed exceedingly
well it actually did did a really good
job guy Gardner was for the most part
headstrong he was a guy who just got in
a fight with Batman Batman punched him
out different things like that but he
also started forming relationships and
one of these relationships was with a
girl named ice a girl named Tora Olaf's
daughter I think is what her last name
is but she's very similar in terms of
Iceman in terms you know with regards to
what her abilities are and so on and so
forth the ability to kind of manipulate
ice and snow and so on and so forth the
idea was that this all really came out
of the aftermath of Sinestro Corps Award
with regards to Guy Gardner and ice
herself the two of them it had this sort
of on-again off-again relationship but
following Sinestro Corps war and him
traveling back to earth the idea was to
basically rekindle this romance
had at some point along the line and
initially the response was well give me
a little bit of time and we'll get
things sorted out which resulted in Guy
Gardner basically retreating back to OA
for about about a month or so in order
to for the two of them to basically get
together and to have a date again
switching back over to you know this
being is going around and killing these
various parents that belong to members
of the Green Lantern Corps this was
really more of a moral assault more so
than a physical assault and the reason
for this is because again historically
speaking when it comes to new recruits
they're very inexperienced they don't
really know how to deal with fear and
you know the Sinestro Corps and so on
and so forth but they're still also very
easy to sway and so the goal of these
creatures at least as it seems on the
surface was to go through kill their
parents make these kids orphans and in
turn embolden them with fear and then
make the members of the Sinestro Corps
but using the powers of serac what is up
happening here as they not only learn
that this one being has been doing this
but there have been a multitude of
others who were all basically of the
same race who are all identical now of
course this leads to the Green Lantern's
tracking them down killing them and you
know that's really the end of that or
the very least filling him into science
cells and that's really the end of that
but the way this begins to lead into the
whole concept of blackest night comes by
way of the scarred Guardian now as far
as I'm aware this Guardian doesn't
actually have a name they're just
referred to as the scarred Guardian but
the Guardian basically speaks directly
with serac and just says look because of
the fact that you can speak directly to
the dead your new assignment that you
will tell nobody about is to go and find
the corpse of the anti-monitor and find
out what in the world is going on now
again the reason why this matters is
because following the events of Sinestro
Corps war one of the things that the
Guardians have been questioning is why
Sinestro had cropped up the way he did
and the other question was what happened
to the anti-monitor because remember if
the anti-monitor is kind of like this
harbinger of death for the multiverse
but when the anti-monitor had basically
been defeated or at the very least when
the events of Sinestro Corps Ward come
to an end
the anti-monitor had been whisked away
and then was effectively turned into a
central power battery or at least that
seemed to be the case so the idea of the
guardians of the universe is to find out
what happened to this guy what in the
world happened to the anti-monitor
and where did he go and so what we end
up doing here is we jump into sins of
the Star Sapphire proper and we
basically just kind of pick up with you
know regards to Mongols still going on
his rampage that is to say leaving the
planet of the black mercies and then
just taking off to the far side of the
universe or whatever but along the way
he comes across
couple and basically destroys their ship
in the process as well as kills one of
them know again this sets the stage for
the idea of the star sapphires and we'll
talk a little bit more about them here
in a second but at the moment one of the
other things that we start focusing on
here is the idea that some Green
Lantern's out there are engaged in
relationships with one another whether
they're guys and guys girls and girls
guys and girls whatever the case may be
they're all forming their own
relationships their own you know
connections and so on and so forth and
some of them have gone so far as to
procreate now this was literally
something the Green Lantern's were just
given free reign on there was really no
limit to what it was a Green Lantern's
could do with their own relationships
they could form friendships they could
form romantic attachments so on and so
forth but in truth when it came to the
Green Lantern's this was something that
actually helped to forge willpower this
is something that gave them a reason to
fight because when you're a Green
Lantern and you're a parent if you're
not fighting for anything you're
fighting for your for your kid and so it
always gave you the extra motivation
that you needed to keep on keeping on
but we also end up finding out here is
that in addition to these you know
aliens that have been captured and have
been killing parents of Green Lantern
Corps members we also actually find out
that someone's been going around and
killing the parents of Green Lantern
babies and then taking those babies away
but the introduction of the star
sapphires starts to come by way of this
particular woman whose husband was
basically killed when Mongol attacked
their ship now this woman's name is
actually Miri but she's met with the
star sapphires and this begins to
bolster the star sapphire range remember
we already talked about the whole
introduction of star sapphires in the
Jeff Jones Green Lantern run when Carol
Ferris was brought in as one of their
wrenched what seems to be going on here
is that where previously the star
sapphires just wanted like a queen and
they sent out this gem that would
basically grab someone and make them the
Queen what they're doing now is they're
creating rings and so the result is that
these rings are now being sent out into
the universe for the purpose of grabbing
people the difference here is that
unlike the Green Lantern's where these
rings were made and then just dispersed
across the cosmos and sent everywhere
instead the star sapphires are far more
conservative about how their rings get
sent out and who it is that's able to
use them and so the result is that
despite you know Guy Gardner and ice
trying to have a bit of a relationship
together ultimately he's recalled back
to the guardians of the universe and
basically told that he alongside soda
yacht and a handful of others are going
to leave the Guardians on a mission to
the Star Sapphire home planet of xamarin
now again for those of you guys who are
new to the whole Jeff Jones Green
Lantern thing if you're just now joining
our videos with regards to the star
sapphires they weren't actually
guardians with a universe at one point
along the line the difference here is
that when the guardians basically
removed emotion from themselves some of
the female members of the Guardians
disagreed with that and believed that
love was the way by which life could
continue on
any form of normalcy and so the result
was that they broke off and they travel
to the planet xamarin where they found
that the love between a man and a woman
resulted in the formation of this
crystal of sorts now this crystal was
basically used by the zamarons to form
their central power battery and begin
calling themselves as star sapphires and
this is what led into Carol Farris the
girlfriend of Hal Jordan being brought
in as one of the star sapphires way back
in the 1950s 1960s or no I'm not even
there maybe was nineteen seventies
whatever the case may be
when she was rolled in into the end of
the Green Lantern mythos as well as you
know her return and someone is so forth
but what we also end up finding out here
is that were some of the members of the
Sinestro Corps where these rings had
basically been captured by the zamarons
and so on and so forth some of the
female members have been taken by the
star sapphires and brought in for the
purpose of being reconditioned and
that's the nature of the star sapphires
what they basically do because they
believe that love is the absolute thing
that can conquer all the goal is to
basically find individuals who were
devoid of love or who they believed need
love and could also serve as a member of
their of their Lantern Corps bring them
in and then effectively recondition them
and that's what they're doing with
members of the Sinestro Corps these
female members that they've discovered
they basically say look they're filled
with hate they're filled with fear so on
and so forth but we can change them we
can fill them with love and when we do
they will be members of the star
sapphires but that's why I say they
don't just send out rings all
willy-nilly to anybody who wants them
they don't just stand on a street corner
and just say you get a ring and you get
a ring and you're gonna ring instead
there are a lot more conservative in
terms of who gets them and so again it's
really kind of a cool scenario because
what we end up finding out here is that
there's basically irreconcilable
differences the goal of the guardians of
the universe coming here was to
basically say look you can't just go
around creating your own Lantern Corps
because you'll destabilize the universe
love mutates love changes sure two
people fall in love and then somewhere
along the line they may end up breaking
up and because one of them is so in love
they go crazy and kill the other because
they don't want the other person to be
with anybody else just because something
starts out good doesn't mean that it's
going to stay good and that's the whole
basis behind the guardians of the
universe devoting themselves of emotion
is to basically make the case that just
because something can be a certain way
doesn't mean that it should be a certain
way but this is when we start to get
into the nature of the fact that the
Gardeners of the universe basically
become their own enemies now switching
back over to who this person is is going
around and kid
these kids it's actually a character by
the name of crit and as far as I'm aware
this is the first introduction of crib
into the whole idea of the Green Lantern
mythos but what crib has been basically
doing is going around killing off the
parents who were basically Green
Lantern's and then taking their kids
with the intention of whisking these
kids away and then raising them to
become Sinestro Corps members to hate
Green Lantern's now this is not as
though crib is functioning in
subservience - Sinestro this is one of
those instances where you see some
existing ruler who's basically defeated
and then petty warlords start rising up
and for the most part that's pretty
standard Wendall Sinestro was still
around before he was captured by the
Green Lantern Corps uh he was the
absolute ruler he was a guy who was
running the show but with his defeat
there was no one in control and so what
this did is a lot of different members
of the Sinestro Corps to go around and
start practicing their own agendas and
so this is really just kind of an
example of how the Sinestro Corps is
fragmented but they're all still
extremely dangerous and what it is that
makes cribs so dangerous is the fact the
crib keeps secrete these pheromones that
will basically force other people to
exist under its control and so again
getting back into the Guardians
themselves the reason why they really
become their own enemy in this
particular story is because when they
look at the star sapphires and they look
at what the star sapphires are doing
they look at the actions that they're
committing themselves to in terms of
spreading love all throughout the
universe and so on and so forth because
the guardians of the universe consider
love to be a weakness and a failing and
something that will inevitably lead
somebody down the path of becoming a
member of the Sinestro Corps they
effectively banish all relationships
among Green Lantern's and so anybody
who's a member of the Green Lantern
Corps cannot be in any kind of a
romantic relationship whatsoever they
cannot date they cannot procreate
none of that stuff they have to remain
totally isolated from one another and
the result of that is going to be
exactly what you expect but the fact
remains here with regards to Kyle Rayner
and these various guys fighting against
the character of crib after realizing
what it is that's going on this
coincides with miry basically coming
along and officially being inducted into
the star sapphire core as the result is
that her job is to effectively go out
find people who are trying to destroy
love anywhere in the universe
and then bring them back to the planet
of xamarin that's the nature of the star
sapphires it's almost like the Sinestro
Corps when a person is so strong that
all they do is instill fear or something
like that they rule with
and fist or they make other people
terrified of them they're effectively a
bully a Sinestro Corps ring will
suddenly pop up and say such-and-such
you have the ability to instill great
fear welcome to the Sinestro Corps that
kind of a thing the zamarons will
basically pop up with a ring that says
you know you have the ability to create
great love or whatever in the world that
it is and then wish them off to become a
member of the others star sapphires and
so the result is that where things are
popping off pretty readily back with hal
kyle rayner and prayer band all these
different guys and so on and so forth
there are two things that happen here
the first is a kyle Rainer's will power
effectively overrides the control they
crib puts on him this is yet another
instance of really detailing the
willpower of kyle rayner
there's a reason why he was the host of
the willpower entity when he was I on
because he is in a lot of ways the
living embodiment of will now of course
this is a role that will be passed on to
Hal Jordan in the new 52 going into DC
rebirth but at this moment right now in
terms of how he acts in terms of his
total lack of fear in terms of his
ability to maintain his mental faculties
in almost any situation Kyle Rayner is
effectively the embodiment of willpower
and this coincides with the arrival of
Miri as a member of the star sapphires
and so again because Star Sapphire Rings
are best utilized against red lantern
rings which they can basically shut down
if they make a member of the Red
Lanterns feel loved and because they
cannot be affected by the orange lantern
ring of avarice while they're not the
most effective against a Sinestro Corps
range they're not like super effective
against them the actions of Miri here
actually helps a sort of Concord crib
just because of the fact that Mira's
presence is indicative of the fact that
crib is basically trying to separate a
mother from its baby and so the result
is that with the help of Miri as a star
sapphire the Green Lantern's are
basically able to defeat crib and the
result is that the baby is born pretty
healthy or as healthy as a baby can be
under this particular circumstance but
following this what Miri also does is
she actually invokes the desires of both
Kyle Rayner as well as a ceramic nattu
of course the daughter of Sinestro she
basically says look the two of you all
need love love is a necessity love is
something that has to exist and this
again is kind of a funny situation
because what this does is it highlights
the nature of Green Lantern's Green
Lantern's are not like the guardians of
the universe the guardians of the
universe purge themselves of all emotion
but the Green Lantern's have not purged
themselves of emotion they feel anger
they feel love
they feel hate they feel fear which is
why so many green lanterns are always in
danger of falling to the Sinestro Corps
falling to the Red Lanterns because of
the fact that they feel emotion as the
result is that mirrors you know Mary
simply says if you do not believe that
love is necessary then simply look into
the gem of the star sapphire I don't
know what it'll show you and neither of
you know where it will show the other
all you know is what you see and we're
not told explicitly what it is the kyle
rayner or sir onyx eat but the idea is
that given what we and what ends up
happening later on with the two of them
kind of bumping uglies that they end up
getting together more or less that is
kind of see each other in love but the
biggest action of this the biggest
result of this particular circumstance
the fall out of the guardians of the
universe effectively banishing love
between the Green Lantern's is that
there are countless Green Lantern's not
really countless but there are hundreds
if not thousands of Green Lantern's that
abandon their post they basically say if
I'm not allowed to be in a relationship
with a person that I love so long as I'm
a Green Lantern then I'm not going to be
a Green Lantern and again this makes
sense because remember not everybody who
was inducted into the Green Lantern
Corps did it willingly not only that a
lot of people came from their own lives
they basically had their own wives their
own husbands they had their own families
they undertook that role because they
felt a responsibility to keep the
universe protected and the power of the
Green Lantern would ensure that their
families protected more so than they
could just by using whatever natural
talents they had but their loyalty is to
their friends and family not to the
Green Lantern's and so what ends up
happening here is it again because the
fact that they're faced with this choice
to either continue their relationships
or abandon the Green Lantern Corps they
abandon the Green Lantern Corps and this
reduces their number by a pretty good
margin in a pretty short amount of time
now those numbers will bolster and those
numbers will go back up but in the
interim blackest night is coming and so
the result is at the war of light it's
gonna be something to behold it's gonna
be absolutely bonkers by the time it's
all said and done but at this point we
start to get out of the realm of the
stories that are interesting but not the
greatest and we start to get into the
stories that are really good like rage
of the red lanterns and like Agent
Orange ah man you know I love Larfleeze
but let me know down in the in the
comments section because I'm kind of
curious let me know in the comment
section which Lantern Corps is your
favor because I'm kind of curious I
imagine people imagine a lot of you
we're gonna say red of
as well people gonna be like yeah man
those Red Lanterns man they're just
pissed off all the time I have no idea
ok so as I mentioned when we started
doing really everything after Sinestro
Corps thwart that there was something
like five or six different preludes to
blackest night because blackest night is
such a huge event it's like the war of
light so it's blackest night as bright
as today there's a lot of stuff that
goes on there but this is actually a pre
lude to rage of the Red Lanterns
which is a prelude to blackest night so
this is like a prelude to a pre loop but
it gets pretty cool in terms of how all
this unfolds because what this does is
this deals with the early formation of
the Red Lantern Corps but it really also
deals with this coming together of the
war of light now the cool thing about
this is that this initially focuses on
the nature of individuals who are
basically becoming what are called alpha
lanterns and alpha lanterns are actually
a pretty cool concept and the reason why
is because these are basically policemen
for the Green Lantern's themselves and
we'll actually get into that here in a
second what we end up doing is we
actually pick up with Sinestro now for
those of you guys who were just now
joining us Sinestro Corps war was really
like the last big event that we did and
that's really the only thing you need to
know in order to be able to follow this
bit of a story here but what ended up
happening is that the former Green
Lantern Sinestro had basically long
since defected from a Green Lantern
Corps after basically being shunned
aside and then making himself a yellow
lantern only for us to find out that he
eventually came along and formed his own
Lantern Corps called the Sinestro Corps
now initially the arrival of the
Sinestro Corps came by way of these
small little things it would pop up here
and there it wasn't any great big huge
event but just suddenly happened it was
just these small little tidbits these
small little teasers that would crop up
every once in a while suddenly a Lantern
ring would appear before Bruce Wayne and
it would say Batman you have the ability
to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps or
something along those lines but winded
up happening is that with this Sinestro
Corps war while the Sinestro Corps was
defeated the overarching goal of
Sinestro was not to eliminate the Green
Lantern's in their entirety although it
would have been nice if he had the goal
was to irrevocably change the nature of
the Green Lantern's
so they no longer serve their purpose
anymore now for those of you guys who
are reading Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern Corps in DC rebirth or you were
reading Green Lantern's
why're 2dc rebirth didn't you know the
long game that Sinestro's playing and
really the kind of offer a bit of a
spoiler for what it is that he's doing
later on down the line at least you know
this is stuff that will cover I don't
know in like six or seven months it'll
be a while before we get there but the
idea who is that the Green Lantern's
always existed as a peacekeeping force
and so they didn't really have the
ability to kill people they would simply
just use their rings to take them
prisoner and then whisk the bad guys
away that was the only role they played
but now the Green Lantern's have the
ability to use lethal force there what
this means is that people will start to
look at the Green Lantern's in a
different eye you'll begin to look at
them as killers and so all Sinestro has
to do is sit back and let the court of
public opinion play its role and
ultimately people will begin to turn on
the green lanterns that's ultimately
what ends up happening with regards to
Sinestro taking over the universe really
you know using the Sinestro Corps as his
own personal army different things like
that but again the funny thing about
this is this hits home at the nature
that Sinestro effectively won that he
won the Sinestro Corps war sure he was
taken prisoner most of his guys were
killed but at the end of the day he won
because the goal of Sinestro was to
spread fear and that's exactly what he
did he instilled fear in a Lantern Corps
that otherwise existed to overcome fear
and so it's this really really good
example of if you're trying to conquer a
country you don't invade the country
that's not what you do you don't go into
a country invade it and call it a day
what you do is you get the government of
that country to turn its guns on its
citizens and then eventually it'll turn
into an uprising a revolt and when that
country's at its weakest then you
conquer it that's exactly how Sinestro
plays this stuff out and so we ended up
doing here is joining a handful of
different people who are basically
coping with the loss of different Green
Lantern's that had perished during the
Sinestro Corps war but one of the most
important characters here and really the
star of this particular story is a girl
named Lyra one of the members of the
lost lanterns now the reason why I say
lost lanterns if you're just now joining
us or if you've been watching this for a
little while bear with me for a second
for the for the new folks back in 1993
when Hal Jordan became a bad guy he was
basically possessed by the parallax
entity which is to say the entity that
represents all all fear that exists in
the universe the result was that Hal
Jordan became a bad guy he laid waste to
the entirety of the Green Lantern Corps
it was believed that he had killed them
all
ended up finding out is that some of the
original green lanterns that were
believed to have been killed by Hal
Jordan actually survived and they were
being held captive by cyborg superman
and the Manhunters of course you'll find
all this stuff in our Green Lantern
playlist if you want to if you want to
get caught up but the idea here was that
these lanterns who were previously
believed to have been dead and then
discovered to have been alive are what
are referred to as the lost lanterns but
the thing that differentiates them from
all the other lanterns that are out
there is that while they are basically
making their return they're essentially
veterans they had been fighting as Green
Lantern's for quite some time
not only that they all Harbor just this
extreme hatred for Hal Jordan because
the last memory they have of him he
turned against them all and tried to
kill him but the character of Lyra is
one of the lost lanterns she's
experienced nothing but just trial in
torment one of the things they talk
about here in little woth is that her
father had basically committed suicide
and the result of this is that with her
father having been a renegade having
basically been a shunned Lantern lost
his honor Lyra was carrying this around
no matter where she went as a green
lantern no matter what she did people
always saw her as the daughter of a
shunned Lantern and so with that legacy
following her around combined with the
fact that she'd been betrayed by Hal
Jordan and then now lost one of her
fellow lost lanterns her life is
literally in turmoil and so what is it
happening here is that on the journey
back to the home planet of ki Han
whether basically taking his body back
to his family once the lost lanterns
arrive they basically end up finding out
that every single person had been killed
now this had been done by character
named Amon Seward
now the cool thing about this is that if
you are pretty new to Green Lantern Amon
Sora is the son of a dancer and a dance
or was the guy who crash-landed on earth
and basically told his ring find a new
host and his ring found Hal Jordan and
so because of this Amon sewer always
believed that he should have been the
heir to his father's ring now when it
comes to the Green Lantern mythos that's
not unprecedented it's not like a man's
sword has kind of came out of nowhere
with this belief system that's happened
quite a few times when it comes to
different different lanterns that are
out there I believe tomar Rey was the
father and tomar - is the son but when
it comes to the different green lanterns
that are out there there are times where
a Green Lantern will perish in battle
and then their offspring will take up
the mantle and so again it's kind of a
cool scenario and an Amon saw believed
that he should have been in line
where's father's ring the result is that
how Jordan got it instead and Ayman Sora
had been consistently plotting ways to
basically bring down Hal Jordan now all
of this coincided with the emergence of
the Sinestro Corps and Ayman store being
given a ring but what this did is it led
to its most logical conclusion when
Ayman saw basically is the one that
killed the entire family of ki Han and
then Lyra in her anger and her rage
basically lashes out and kills Ayman
Seward now here's the interesting thing
about this with the Sinestro Corps
despite the fact that they had these
rings that allow them to do all kinds of
different things when it comes to the
different cores that exist in the DC
mythos they all exist to feed off of
emotion so the Green Lantern's feed on
willpower so long as there's somebody
out there who's willing to stand up you
know and say I'm not afraid then there
will be willpower in the universe at the
same time so long as there's somebody
there who says oh my god I'm so scared
that things might go bad there will
always be fear in the universe as long
as there's somebody who's angry as long
as there's somebody who loves as long as
there's life as long as there's death
those aspects of the emotional spectrum
will always exist and the course will
always be there and so because of this
Amon saw believed that he could
basically turn himself into a martyr
that what he could do is he could allow
himself or he could go through kill the
family of ki Han and then other members
of the Sinestro Corps would see how this
impacted existing Green Lantern's and in
turn take up the same task and literally
just start killing off families of Green
Lantern's who exist again sowing chaos
reaping war you know guerrilla warfare
tactics against a far more organized and
structured Lantern Court especially
considering that the Sinestro Corps does
not have their leader Sinestro because
he's currently held in prison and so
with the death of Amon Sewer what
happens here is his ring basically just
takes off to seek out a viable host it
ends up attempting to bond itself to the
Scarecrow now the funny thing about this
is that this is actually a teaser of
things to come because the Scarecrow is
gonna play a pretty cool role once we
start getting into like blackest night
and brightest day and different things
like that where the ring initially
appears to him with the intention of
bonding itself of course Hal Jordan and
John Stewart show up they basically
saved the day and nothing happens you
know that scarecrow doesn't end up
getting a ring but what this does is
this leads into the trial of Lyra when
it came to the Sinestro Corps war one of
the major laws that was basically
implemented by the guardians of the
universe was that those individuals
who are members of the Green Lantern
Corps have authorization to use lethal
force against members of a Sinestro
Corps and that's literally the argument
that liar uses she says who cares why I
killed him what he what matters is that
he was a villain you know he did some
terrible things he killed a family of ki
Han he deserved to die
and so I killed him now her argument is
not without merit let's say for example
she didn't kill a man sort and let's say
that a monster was captured for his
crimes he was brought back to OA and
then he escaped well that would mean he
would go right back to doing what he was
doing before he would go right back to
killing people why sacrifice the lives
of others that's basically the argument
is being made you know from the Green
Lanterns when the guardians of the
universe is hey look you know justice is
the most important thing and so yes this
guy killed children but he deserves a
fair trial just like everybody else no
he does he gave up that right when he
murdered a family he sacrificed that
that's the choice that he made he looked
at the consequences of his own actions
and said if I commit this crime then
there's a good chance somebody's gonna
come and kill me and I don't care why
give that chance why go to a three year
old or a four year old or an 80 year old
woman and say hey look yeah there's a
chance you're gonna die and Aemon sewers
gonna be the one to kill you and it's
suck sure that's gonna happen but you
know it's just the price we pay when it
comes to justice I mean I don't know
what to tell you it doesn't work that
way that guy made a choice he paid the
price and the result is that the Green
Lantern's effectively turn on Lyra now
what this also does is this brings in
something called the Alpha lanterns and
the reason for this is because the
actions of Lyra throw into sharp relief
that there are going to be Green
Lantern's out there who are going to
basically look at the rules as they
exist and then interpret them different
ways and that's the problem is that
these rules are not absolute these rules
are basically written in a way where
anybody can look at them you can show
the rules to five different people and
give them each a certain stance and
they'll interpret the rules in different
ways the law says lethal force can be
used against a member of the Sinestro
Corps
it does not say lethal force can be used
against a member of the Sinestro Corps
but only if they're trying to attack you
it doesn't say that and so in truth she
has all legitimate means to make this
case what the Guardians basically do is
that instead of coming along and saying
okay we are going to make a law and then
we're going to add stipulations to that
law for every conceivable
circumstance that could possibly exist
what they end up doing is they come
along and they create the Alpha lanterns
and the Alpha lanterns serve the purpose
of basically being field police they're
the ones that show up if a green lantern
goes out and commits something they
shouldn't do but technically speaking
they fall within the confines of the law
the Alpha lanterns will respond and the
Alpha lanterns will analyze the
situation they'll be the ones to
basically decide whether this Lantern
was right or wrong
now the question has to be asked how
does this fix anything what's different
from the Alpha lanterns showing up and
saying yep they're right - just another
arbitrary Green Lantern showing up and
saying no they're wrong the reason why
this matters is because if you're new to
the whole Green Lantern mythos back when
the guardians of the universe first
tried to create order tried to instill
order across the universe they created
what we're called the Manhunters and the
Manhunters were basically these robots
that were tasked with the purpose of
keeping the universe safe the problem
with this is that the Manhunters
programming eventually went awry they
basically became bad guys it is sort of
cutting a swath through the universe
killing all different forms of life on
the name of order and justice and so
eventually the guardians of the universe
had to do away with the Manhunters and
in turn began creating the Green Lantern
Corps under the idea that Green
Lantern's would be able to use their own
experiences their own understanding of
right and wrong and then decide what
action needs to be taken all of which
was predicated on the fact that before
Sinestro Corps war Green Lantern's
couldn't kill and so the idea that Green
Lantern's can kill complicates
everything and so what ends up happening
here is that where individuals are
basically chosen to become alpha
lanterns and jon stewart's one of them
Jon Stewart actually turns them down Jon
Stewart actually says no he doesn't want
to be any part of that and the reason
why is because the Guardians say the
Alpha lanterns will exist to basically
serve the purpose of enforcing the ten
laws that the guardians of the universe
have put into creation the problem with
this is that only two of those laws are
known and so those individuals who
signed up to become alpha lanterns don't
know what other laws they're gonna be
forced to implement they could very well
be forced to implement laws that say
it's illegal to fly from one side of the
universe to the other on a Thursday we
have no idea what these laws are going
to be I mean there would be anything
that ridiculous but you guys understand
what I'm saying they're basically
signing up to enforce rules that they
don't know anything about what the awful
lanterns do is basically stand as this
sort of combination of machinery
and biological organisms they're
effectively cyborgs or at least they
seem to be that way now the reason why
this is so cool is because Green
Lantern's traditionally which is to say
Hal Jordan John Stuart kyle rayner Guy
Gardner they have to charge their rings
their rings will run low the reason why
this is important is because with the
Alpha lanterns they don't have that
problem the Alpha lanterns main line the
central power battery and so it's like
the difference between you having a
remote control that runs off batteries
and having a remote control that plugs
in from the wall at the end of the day
they do serve the same purpose but one
is not going to run out of power as long
as you have power going to your house
and so what is up happening here is that
where Lara just immediately loses it
when everybody basically says okay look
you know you are effectively guilty
we're going to hold you accountable for
your crimes the Alpha lanterns begin the
process of essentially arresting her but
in this particular circumstance the
Alpha lanterns begin to demonstrate this
sort of totalitarian position
we're saw most likely to start executing
or at least they intend to execute Myra
on the spot now this is important
because what this does is it sets the
stage for the possibility of the
guardians of the universe repeating
their mistakes again the Guardians of
the Universe have consistently shown
themselves to be extremely intelligent
and very capable they're able to make
mistakes just like everybody else they
can't see the future they don't know
everything about everything and the
Alpha lanterns are a perfect example of
that
creating a police force within the Green
Lantern's with virtually no oversight is
going to end in nothing good it's going
to cause all kinds of problems and so
what is up happening here is that what
the first law having already been
written
what the Guardians do is they come along
and they basically write in stone the
second law and the second law is that
anybody who is an enemy of the Green
Lantern Corps will be met with lethal
force by the Green Lantern's now this is
important because what end up happening
is during Sinestro Corps the Guardians
of the Universe said lethal force is
authorized
against the Sinestro Corps that was it
it was only against the Sinestro Corps
now again this hits back home to the
conversation that Hal Jordan has with
Sinestro where Sinestro says I told you
I was right I told you that I won this
war because now that the Green Lantern's
can use lethal force against anybody
who's an enemy of the Green Lantern
where does that stop is an enemy of the
Green Lantern a person that's running
for political
this that disagrees with Green Lanterns
is an enemy of the Green Lanterns a
person standing on a street corner
saying I don't believe the Green
Lantern's are right where do you draw
this line at what point do you say yes
this person is an enemy but they're not
a mortal enemy they're not going to
actually do us any harm
you know this allows this the stage to
be set for the Green Lantern's to be
transformed from a peacekeeping force
into a militaristic controlling force
effectively becoming exactly what
Sinestro wanted them to be where they
used fear and they used force to
maintain order across the universe as
opposed to allowing people to basically
live their own lives and so what is up
happening here is to basically pick up
with Lyra as she's being transported
back to her planet because again what a
person's found guilty of a crime like
this in the Green Lantern's they're
basically just kicked out that's really
all it is it's just you're banned from
the Green Lantern Corps and you're sent
back home now for a lot of people this
is a big deal because remember when a
person's given a Green Lantern ring a
massive amount of power comes with that
the Green Lantern ring becomes as much
their identity as it becomes a source of
power in this instance that was the only
way for Lyra to at least as far as she
perceived it to regain the honor lost by
her father but being kicked out of the
Green Lantern means she's now just the
daughter of a father who was shamed and
who was shunned for his actions as a
renegade Lantern and basically just
kicked out of the Corps and so because
of this in this moment when she just
swears absolute vengeance against you
know against anybody you know that
that's considered to be an enemy of her
or at least all the other members of the
Sinestro Corps she suddenly met with the
arrival of a Red Lantern ring and this
marks chronologically the first time in
DC Comics that the Red Lanterns actually
make their appearance for the secret
origin of Hal Jordan that we did earlier
and when we started the whole Green
Lantern thing technically speaking that
happens after this but the cool thing
about this is that this is the first
introduction of the Red Lanterns into DC
the first time that we actually see a
Lantern Corps that's predicated on
absolute pure and unadulterated rage
oh my goodness rob cor I woke up this
morning I had a leisurely breakfast of
steak and eggs
I was watching World War Z the book is
still better than the movie and we are
getting ready to cover rage of the Red
Lanterns so this story is amazing oh my
god this is so good because this is like
I think it's this and then it's Agent
Orange which is Larfleeze and then we go
into blackest night so we've got like
two weeks until we start blackest night
which I'm really kind of hyped about
because that story is insanely good but
for those of you guys who were just now
getting caught up with us here on our
Green Lantern Sundays I guess is what it
is
the Green Lantern landscape so far has
basically dealt with Sinestro Corps war
which is to say the villain Thal
Sinestro a former Green Lantern who
basically became corrupted by his power
falling and then forming his own yellow
lantern court this really led into a
series of paradigm shifts where the
Green Lantern's were always more of a
peacekeeping force because of the
violence of Sinestro because his rings
were not limited by the ability to kill
like the Green Lantern rings were they
couldn't actually kill people the
guardians of the universe the creators
of the Green Lantern Corps basically
modified the rules of the Rings so that
Green Lantern's could now kill people
and this was the ultimate goal of Thal
Sinestro was to basically turn the Green
Lantern's or at least begin the process
of taking the universes I how they
perceived the Green Lantern's and move
it away from seeing the Green Lantern's
as protectors to seeing the Green
Lantern's as really more of like a
police force like this sort of army you
know belonging to these all-powerful
beings
I would lead people down the path of
coming to believe that the Green
Lantern's were effectively paving the
way for the guardians of the universe to
take over the universe yes not what was
actually happening all the fal Sinestro
needed was the belief that that's what
was gonna happen
now what this does is it shifts over to
the Red Lanterns - Atrocitus now
Atrocitus is a character that we haven't
really talked about since we cover the
secret origin story of how Jordan the
Green Lantern but Atrocitus was formerly
a guy I think his name was at Rose who
was formerly just a guy residing in
Sector six-six-six just one of the many
sectors that exists all throughout the
universe when it comes to DC Comics the
universe is divided into sections into
sectors so think of the universe or
think of the sectors of the universe is
like neighborhoods more or less is the
best way to think of it but the idea
here is that when the guardians of the
universe
before they created the green lanterns
they had what were called the Manhunters
the idea was that if there was going to
be a peacekeeping force around the
universe then the best way to do that
was to use robots because robots were
only governed by their programming
they weren't governed by emotion they
weren't governed by fear rage anger
wrath any of those things
now this eventually led to the
programming of the Manhunters going awry
and one of the first casualties of their
screwed up programming was Sector 666
and at this time the family of Atrocitus
was basically destroyed in the conflict
now the reason why this matters is
because what happened following this is
Atrocitus was just set by absolute pure
rage now as we know rage is one of the
aspects of the emotional spectrum
remember when it comes to the whole
Green Lantern mythos the Blue Lantern
rings of Hope the orange Lantern ring of
avarice or greed the yellow Lantern ring
of fear they're all tied into the
emotional spectrum so long as there's an
emotion of rage so long as somebody in
the universe is mad as hell there will
always be a source of energy for the red
lanterns and so because of this a lot of
what this early story really does is
just kind of flesh out the nature of
Atrocitus forming his own Red Lantern
Corps now again all this really required
in order for a person to be able to form
a Corps is to tap into the emotional
spectrum but it's easier said than done
it really just requires somebody to be
so angry that it basically encompasses
their heart they become the living
embodiment of rage when that happens
it's almost like going super saiyan for
the first time in Dragonball right let
just kind of manifest these new powers
and abilities with with the Green
Lantern's they just suddenly pop out a
power battery and they're able to tap
into this emotional spectrum now again
what this does is it leads to Atrocitus
becoming the first of the Red Lanterns
now the other half of this is again this
continued fallout of Sinestro Corps war
and again we cover that we talked about
that during the Sinestro Corps war
proper we said that that story was going
to lay the groundwork for a lot of
things that came after and there were
gonna be a lot of threads coming out of
that that we're going to continue on one
of the things that takes place here and
really one of the the major threads that
leads directly into blackest night is
what it was that happened to the
anti-monitor
the anti-monitor is basically the
harbinger of the death of the multiverse
you know whenever the multiverse comes
into existence you know it died during
crisis on Infinite Earths it came back
during Infinite Crisis whenever the
multiverse exists the anti-monitor will
all
Manifest with it because the
anti-monitor is just the living
embodiment of the death of the
multiverse is the best way to describe
it the result of this is that the
anti-monitor allied itself with the
Sinestro Corps now at the end of
Sinestro Corps war the eighty monitor
was more or less defeated and just kind
of shot out into space but what we ended
up finding out is that some unknown
being they basically grabbed
anti-monitor
and turned him into a central power
battery what this also does is it brings
into sharp relief the idea of this
scarred guardian now I don't think the
scarred guardian actually has a name all
we really know is that this is one of
the guardians of the universe that has
basically grabbed one of the Green
Lantern's by the name of ash and sent
him on a mission of finding out what
happened to the anti-monitor
and this is inevitably going to pave the
way for the introduction of blackest
night but at this point information is
just scant I mean it's it's so scarce
we'll get a little bit more into what
the prophecy of the blackest night means
as we get through this but what is up
happening here is the Green Lantern's
Hal Jordan Guy Gardner Jon Stewart
they're tasked with basically escorting
thousand estro to his execution Green
Lantern's don't necessarily execute one
of their own if they like abuse their
power but with all Sinestro is a whole
different beast because not only he
abused his power and find himself booted
out of the Green Lantern Corps he in
turn formed his own Lantern Corps and
then tried to kill Green Lantern's and
so he's basically considered guilty of
high treason against the guardians of
the universe and the lanterns and so
because of this what ends up happening
is that in the midst of him basically
being taken to his imminent execution
the most logical scenario unfolds when
we end up having the Sinestro Corps
really just kind of pop out of nowhere
for the purpose of attacking the Green
Lantern's now again all this seems to be
the workings of the scarred guardian
behind the scene the scarred Guardian
was the one who informed the various
members of the Sinestro Corps the ones
who were left the thousand s rows being
escorted to his destination to Kruger
the scarred Guardian is the one that
basically passed all this information on
so that the Sinestro Corps would know
exactly where to hit him but the caveat
to this is that in the midst of the
Green Lantern's escorting Thal Sinestro
and being ambushed by the Sinestro Corps
they're met with the unexpected arrival
of the Red Lantern so now again the
reason why Atrocitus is really chasing
after Sinestro the reason why he harbors
such hatred for him is because of the
fact that during the secret origins
story that we had talked about the one
flying down in the description alongside
all the other Green Lantern videos in
the playlist fall Sinestro was the guy
who basically defeated Atrocitus back
when Atrocitus had really just kind of
popped up for one of the first hunts the
result was that once the trosset US was
taken back and dropped on the planet of
islam he basically made a prophecy that
a time would come when Thal Sinestro's
home planet of kuru Girt would descend
into chaos and madness and in an attempt
to control it Thal Sinestro would
basically become a dictator he would
effectively cast aside the role of the
Green Lantern and essentially become a
villain and that's exactly what happened
now remember the reason why this happens
is because the five inversions who were
the five survivors of the assault on
Sector 666 by the Manhunters alongside
Atrocitus they had the ability to cast
spells to dehl to delve into sorcery
different things like that that would
let them see the future and so what
ended up happening is when the five
inversions looked into the future they
saw what Sinestro would become the
events that would lead him to this very
moment
now that Sinestro initially avoided it
just said no that's not gonna happen I'm
not worried about that but ultimately it
all proved itself to be true the crazy
thing about this is that when it comes
to the various lanterns of how they
interact with one another
different lanterns have different
effects on other Lantern cores for
example what we end up having here is
the red lanterns who basically just
begin burning away the power of every
single Lantern that they come across the
Green Lantern ring of Hal Jordan begins
to become corrupted and what happens is
he suddenly met by the arrival of a guy
he's never seen before named Saint
Walker who claims to be a Blue Lantern
now here's a crazy thing I do not
understand why it is that that Green
Lantern fans love st. Walker the closest
thing I can get to it the only
explanation I can come up with is the
blue lanterns are basically like the
Jedi of the DC Universe that's really it
they're just kind of like monks and
they're like all will be well I mean
it's one of those it's one of those
weird things but this is what I'm
talking about when I say rings can
compliment others the Blue Lantern rings
have the ability to basically recharge
Green Lantern rings and even supercharge
them and so again having a Blue Lantern
in your corner basically bolsters the
powers of a Green Lantern now there are
also other aspects of the blue lanterns
but in terms of where they come from in
terms of how they got here what we know
is that in the aftermath of the Sinestro
Corps war we basically had this prophecy
of blackest night now the prophecy of
blackest night again was another
from the five inversions they had looked
into the future and they had seen
there's gonna be this massive war of
light that basically what's going to
happen is that all the different lantern
cores are gonna fight one another the
entire emotional spectrum is basically
going to be obliterated all life in
existence is going to vanish and it'll
be nothing but blackness the blackest
night is quite literally what it sounds
like now the idea and is that the
guardians of the universe were warned by
a dancer the predecessor to Hal Jordan
the guy who crash-landed on earth told
his ring to go find a replacement which
chose Hal Jordan that guy a dancer had
been told of the prophecy of blackest
night by Atrocitus a dancer had reported
his findings to the guardians of the
universe and they chose to ignore it
what ended up happening in the
significance of the Sinestro Corps war
is it brought into sharp relief other
Lantern cores are starting to pop up the
zamarons the women are I guess that the
different aspects of the guardians of
the universe who used to be Malthusians
or women or whatever who broke off and
began tapping into the love aspect of
the emotional spectrum they have their
own core now we have the Red Lanterns we
have the Sinestro Corps all we're
missing now are the white lanterns of
black Lantern's we haven't gotten to the
orange lanterns yet we have all these
different Lantern cores popping up and
when the guardians of the universe began
to realize what was going on a majority
of them ignored everything that was
happening they said no the prophecy of
the blackest night is a myth
it's not going to happen we don't need
to worry about that but a couple of them
ganthet and sayd believed that it was
true and so because of this ganthet and
sayd basically took the steps in saying
we need to make sure that if the
prophecy of blackest night is true that
we're prepared for is better to be
prepared for something that won't happen
and to not be prepared for something
that will happen and so because of that
what they ended up doing is forming
their own Lantern Corps the blue
lanterns now in terms of how this core
hell's core functions on how this core
exists this actually comes by way of
saint walker himself and what he ends up
doing is taking Hal Jordan to a planet
called Odom at least I think it's called
Odom their how it's pronounced but what
we end up finding out is that with the
Green Lantern cores or like the Red
Lantern Corps even the Sinestro Corps
something like that you're basically
like the reader just kind of sent out
into the universe
you know the reisel be made and it'll
just be like okay just go out of there
and just find a replacement a person
will just be bonded with the rain for
whatever reason either they they instill
great fear or they have great rage in
their heart or they have the ability to
overcome great fear whatever the case
may be and they'll just kind of
just be sent to training and they'll
become a member of that Court with
regards to the blue lanterns it's not
that way what happens here is that they
are far more strict when it comes to
inducting members into their group the
process takes days and weeks of person
is brought before the blue lanterns and
they're basically sent to this massive
ritual now the reason for this is
because of the fact that the blue
lanterns are largely considered to be
the most powerful Lantern Court now this
is before the emergence of the white
lanterns to be honest but with regards
to the blue lanterns at this point in
time they're considered to be the most
powerful because there's hope now the
blue lanterns in terms of what they can
do again can basically cleanse a person
of the Red Lantern rage and we'll get to
that why you know we'll get to why that
happens here in a second but the idea is
that the blue lanterns are really more
of like a foundation you know I mean
they have abilities and so on and so
forth but the blue lanterns can only
really use their power if they're in the
presence of like a Green Lantern so
everything has checks and balances and
that's the really cool thing about this
it's one of the reasons why the Green
Lantern mythos is so just kind of
intriguing and interesting is because a
ring is powerful against one type of
ring but not against another you know it
complements one of the lantern cores but
not another there's always these
different checks and balances that go
into this whole thing now the other half
of this is that we also pick up with the
idea that really how Jordan is designed
to kind of be this Harbinger for the
blue lanterns the intention is to make
him their leader now this is not readily
made to Hal Jordan instead what we end
up doing is we end up grabbing st.
Walker and the newest introduction to
the Glu Lantern Corps and they're
designed to basically go after and find
Sinestro now the reason for this is
because of the fact that Sinestro is
largely considered to be one of the the
prominent members or a significant
person for the coming war of light we
don't necessarily know why but the
indication here is that of all the
people who need to live it has to be
thought of Sinestro he has to survive
this whole thing and so again that's why
this is so intriguing is because we're
given these little tidbits these little
itty bitty pieces of information about
characters and we're - how important
they are but we're not explicitly told
why now again the reason why this is so
important and is so cool is because for
Hal Jordans character he's been a
trainee of Thal Sinestro he's fought
alongside thousand Sto and he's fought
against thousand Estero but their lives
have basically been intertwined for
years and years and years and years not
only that it's also this idea that once
they
land on the actual home planet of the
Red Lanterns and once it really just
begins you know to get into Hal Jordan
just recollecting on these moments the
experiences the two of them had
previously the discussions they got into
and all these different things the
battles they've had in the conflict they
had even if it's only for a brief moment
Thal Sinestro becomes a friend he's an
ally for a split second when he tells
Hal Jordan to watch out now of course
this leads to the emergence of the Red
Lanterns who of course promptly captured
Hal Jordan it's really this idea that
they've basically captured who people
largely consider to be the two greatest
Green Lantern's in existence now of
course this leads to the arrival of the
Sinestro Corps and again that's why this
is so cool is because this is Geoff
Johns and BC giving us a taste he's like
look right now in this story we're gonna
have the blue entrance and the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps
battling the red lanterns and that's
just for imagine if we had all seven or
eight or how many cores are imagine if
they were all fighting against each
other at the same time and that's the
cool thing is because in the midst of
all this with chaos and pandemonium
reigning supreme Saint Walker they all
just kind of pop up on the scene and
it's like all will be well when the ring
of Hal Jordan begins to deplete the blue
lanterns are there to charge it and that
I think is one of the reasons why fans
love the blue lantern so much because of
Lou lanterns are just kind of like
buiness cool dude just just chill man
chill dude we got this man like it's
just it's it's calm it's relaxation
because they are effectively monks now
one thing when it comes to the idea of
the Red Lanterns when a person is imbued
with a Red Lantern ring they're designed
to basically be mindless the reason for
this is because with Atrocitus being the
first Red Lantern he has full control of
his faculties you'll notice he's not
like any of the other Red Lanterns
Atrocitus thinks he rationalizes he
strategizes he's got all this history he
taunts different things like that the
other Red Lanterns are just mindless
raging beasts because they're not
designed to be tactical they're not
designed to be reasonable to think
things through they're designed to be a
force of nature
they're designed to exist and then
Atrocitus says go attack those guys over
there and then the Red Lanterns just
show up an overwhelming force just
inflicting mass pandemonium and
casualties but when it comes to Hal
Jordan because of the fact that the
former Green Lantern Lyra again we
talked about her in the last video
because of the fact that she basically
been eggs
from the Green Lanterns she absolutely
despised the members of the Sinestro
Corps had a massive amount of Rage
wanted to kill every last one that she
came across and was following that given
a Red Lantern ring a really just kind of
forced into having a Red Lantern ring
she is effectively killed by Sinestro
now the reason why this matters is
because this sins Hal Jordan over the
edge the idea was that he was going to
try to find a way to save Lyra Lyra was
exiled because of the fact that she
basically killed a member of the
Sinestro Corps who had killed the family
of one of her teammates that was really
yes she wasn't like a villain she wasn't
trying to conquer a world she was just
angry and hurting and dealing with it
the best way she knew how
the result was that she was suddenly
bonded with a Red Lantern ring for
Sinestro he's not killing her to spare
Hal Jordans life not by any standard of
measurement he's doing that because he
knows it'll get to Hal Jordan and
because of this Hal Jordan snaps twirl
iris ring takes off and says finding a
new sentient Hal Jordan goes absolutely
berserk and just loses it on Sinestro
literally beating the absolute hell out
of him and in this moment of rage and
this moment of just absolute rampage Hal
Jordan is imbued with a Red Lantern ring
and that's the craziest thing because
this is the worst case scenario really
for almost anybody I mean I would
imagine at the time the story's being
written this is the worst case because
imagine for example that Atrocitus
basically gave Hal Jordan the ability to
be a rational thinking being imagine he
gave him the ability to basically be a
guy who could think on his own Hal
Jordan would literally crush almost
every single Lantern Corps that he came
across this is as close as we get to the
return of parallax one other thing to
keep in mind when it comes to the red
lanterns is that when a person has made
a Red Lantern there's all kinds of
things that come along with it with
regards to like the Green Lantern's for
example let's just take the traditional
Green Lantern all right let's say that
you're sitting at home one day and a
Green Lantern rain just pops up in front
of you and it says you member of the
rock or of course your rock floor ring
can overcome the Green Lantern rain but
nonetheless it pops up in front of you
and it says you have the ability to
overcome great fear welcome to the Green
Lantern Corps you're just whisked away
for training but you can turn down the
ring you can say you know what I don't
want to be a member of the Green Lantern
Corps I'm a member of a better Corps
called the Rob
I don't want to Green Lantern ready at
least I hope you guys don't abandon me
for the Green Lantern's anyway but you
could turn the ring down you could say
you don't want to be a Green Lantern and
the ring will simply say ok searching
for a replacement sentient with the red
lanterns it doesn't work that way put on
the Green Lantern ring and you can take
it off and you have different abilities
and it's all tied gear will power your
ability to overcome fear it's pretty
straightforward when a Red Lantern ring
Bond's itself to you it becomes you you
basically have your heart replaced your
blood is your place with plasma if you
go to take the Red Lantern ring off
you'll die because literally the source
of your ability to exist goes away it's
tantamount to having your heart ripped
out of your body that's exactly the way
it works and so because of this under
any normal circumstance a person bonded
with the Red Lantern ring is going to
die the reason why this is so cool and
the reason why this is so interesting is
because in this moment when Hal Jordan
is basically running over all these
different emotions this pain that he's
feeling this hatred that is feeling this
rage all the things as Sinestro has done
whereas mine in this body are going
through all these physical changes in
response to being given or basically
being possessed by a Red Lantern ring
suddenly st. Walker and company simply
show up and say we have no idea what's
going to happen when we do this but
we're making you a member of the Blue
Lantern Court and the reason why is
because again as part of these checks
and balances the strengths of Lantern
cores versus the weaknesses of other
Lantern Corps so on and so forth the
Blue Lantern ring basically begins the
process of cleansing the person who's
infected with a Red Lantern ring so it
basically is their way out as their
caveat now that makes sense because if
that didn't exist what we basically have
is the Red Lanterns just spreading
across the universe like a plague with
no way to stop them now the idea here is
that with Hal Jordan basically being
given this Blue Lantern ring that works
in conjunction with his Green Lantern
ring he's effectively a hybrid now it's
almost like he has the best of both
worlds which is kind of cool here
because this sets the groundwork for a
lot of things that we'll end up seeing
coming up next but in terms of getting
into this free lude of the whole neo
blackest night this whole scenario we're
basically end up having thousand estro
escaping back to his home planet you
know getting to the antimatter universe
on the planet of cord recharging his
reign using the central power battery
going out grabbing those individuals who
were truly faithful to the Sinestro
Corps killing those individuals who are
not
again this follows a multitude of groups
as we all end up getting into this idea
of the war of life but one of the things
that happens here and one of the things
is interesting is we also end up hinting
at the orange light of avarice now the
Auris light of avarice has not been
discussed yet we haven't really done
anything about it yet that'll be the
next video that we do but the orange
light of avarice is basically the orange
light of greed and it belongs to a
singular guy named Larfleeze now in
terms of why he lives in the Vega system
in terms of why it is the guardians of
the universe have always been hands-off
we'll get into that as we get into his
own individual story but in terms of
like the star sapphires for example
Carol Ferris the girlfriend of Hal
Jordan joining the star sapphires this
comes by way of the fact that with Hal
Jordan basically taking off from Earth
with Carol Ferris having continually
rebuked him she now has a change of
heart she wants him back she wants him
there and because of that when Hal
Jordan is basically off in space and
Carol Ferris takes off to clear her mind
her emotions begin to get the better of
her she begins to feel sadness she
begins to feel a loss of love because of
this this makes her a target for the
star sapphires and so like she was
originally in or at least way back in
the 1950s when she was a star sapphire
this is history repeating itself all
over again and so again that's the basis
behind this rage of the Red Lantern
story yes it deals with the Red Lanterns
but it's also this coming together of
all these different Lantern course
because this is the last piece of the
puzzle until we get to blackest night
okay so it is 12:30 in the morning right
now and I have recorded something like
seven or eight audio files I am
exhausted it's been all day today doing
nothing but reading comics and man I
need to get some rest but PAX West is
coming up this weekend so I gotta prep
ahead of time so we are finally jumping
into blackest night and it is about time
I told you guys the lead-up to blackest
night is huge its massive in scope I
mean it's just it's it's absolutely
mind-boggling because everything we've
covered it really with the beginning of
Green Lantern's secret origin all the
way up to this point has all led to
blackest night so it's actually really
really exciting but one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind is that this comes
as part of the aftermath of the death of
Batman now the way this all plays out
and really the the nature of blackest
night is to kind of hit home
with the idea of character resurrections
filtering us who are new to comic books
and character resurrections were never
really a thing until the death of
Superman and the reason why was because
for the most part when a character was
killed off they usually just stayed dead
there was really no sense of bringing
them back and it was really important
for writers to follow that trend because
whenever they wrote stories were a
character died there was a finality to
it it was the idea that well as
characters dead now and they're never
gonna come back the death of Superman
and then the return of Superman
basically cheapened it it created the
standard where it essentially said so
long as there's some kind of caveat
whether it's time-travel whether it's
going into uh you know healing the
healing matrix whatever it is as long as
a writer creates some sort of caveat any
character can come back so Colossus for
example sacrificed his life in order to
cure the legacy virus this virus that
was just sweeping through the entirety
of the mutant and even human community
like a plague and then following that he
was basically resurrected you know by by
Joss Whedon's so this whole idea that
the characters don't really stay dead
anymore
all really has its roots in the death of
Superman with Batman he essentially died
during Final Crisis now of course we'll
talk a little bit more about this as we
go through this video but the idea here
is that we initially pick up with the
scarred Guardian now we don't really
know who the scarred Guardian is we just
know that it's this Guardian whose face
is scarred now the reason for this is
because this is one of the guardians
that faced off against the anti-monitor
during the events of Sinestro Corps war
now keep in mind the anti-monitor
basically channels antimatter energy
whereas everything in the main DC
Universe is positive energy in this
story it's just the idea that if
positive manner is touched by antimatter
it'll begin to erode and so that's why
the Guardians face is so scarred and so
screwed up is because it was basically
touched by the anti-monitor which began
to erode its face away now the response
to this was that as this Guardian was
essentially on the brink of death it was
suddenly met by the entity necrons one
of the many entities that exists as part
of the emotional spectrum keep in mind
within the DC universe you have the
emotional spectrum and the emotional
spectrum is just a reflection of
sentient life and so as long as there
are beings out there alien human
otherwise who feel anger who feel love
who feel compassion whatever the case
may be that part of the emotional
spectrum will exist because of the fact
that it's fed by those very emotion
mic wise because there are beings that
exist a time will come when they die and
so the Black Lantern Corps represents
the concept of death the idea is that
while this Guardian was basically
experiencing what amounted to near-death
experience so to speak it was met with
nekron because each of these different
parts of the emotional spectrum
basically has a kind of entity that
represents it which is to say all the
emotion in the universe you know all the
fear for example in the universe
coalesce into a being that embodies all
the fear that exists in the universe of
course that being coming in the form of
parallax these are how all these
different things work in the case of a
black Lantern's the concept of death
coalesce into a being called Necron
being that Necron seems to be basically
undefeatable so long as there's life in
existence necron will never die just
because of the fact that you know Necron
represents the concept of something
dying again it gets really kind of crazy
and really sort of mind-boggling when we
get to these levels of thinking but the
cool thing is about this is about as
complicated as it gets so the funny
thing about this is that this guardian
basically gives us this sort of rundown
of the really the history of the
universe when it comes to these various
lanterns as well as you know the
Manhunters that exist so in order to
follow this trend is pretty
self-explanatory but in order to follow
this trend
what we know is that in the beginning
there was just the creation of the
universe
however the universe came into existence
following this there was the very first
race in existence called the mountains
and the mountains had basically evolved
and grown to the point where they
basically came to realize that emotion
was the source of all problems in the
universe a person is struggling
financially
they get angry and in their anger they
get envious in their envy they take what
somebody else has this is basically the
root of all evil emotion itself that's
how they guardians of the universe
viewed it and so the mountains began the
process of basically casting off emotion
now DC rebirth comes back and ties into
a lot of that stuff with volthoom
providing a lot of information we didn't
have before and we'll cover all that
once we get around to like wrath of the
first Lantern and different things like
that
but the long and short of it for this
video right now is that the Malthusians
had basically cast out emotion and then
began the process of creating this sort
of Universal police force which came in
the form of these Android man hunters
now the problem with this is that these
Android man hunters eventually went awry
now this all ties into the end to
something called crona's gauntlet which
is to say a very primitive version of
the Green Lantern rings basically and
what we know is that Corona was one of
the Malthusians one of the guardians of
the universe who wanted to see the
beginning of all things as though the
result was that when he did this he
effectively created all evil he
basically came you know more or less
went back in time and created the
anti-monitor leading to the collapse of
the multiverse and all that kind of
crazy stuff but the idea here is that
with Crona being a bad guy Crona
actually messed with the programming of
the of the Manhunters which in turn
symptom on this murderous crusade that's
where the red lanterns come from and all
those things but in response to the
Manhunters going awry becoming evil the
guardians of the universe came to the
realization that if sentient beings are
what basically power the emotional
spectrum then the best way to tap into
the emotional spectrum is to use
sentient beings but in order to do that
they can't just give them all kinds of
crazy power there have to be these sort
of standards these checks and balances
that ensure that if a person is given a
ring that allows them to channel
directly into the emotion of willpower
that they won't use it for evil deeds
now of course we know that Sinestro
ended up doing that but the idea was
that the guardians of the universe
created the Green Lantern race and then
had them go out and seek people who were
deemed to be worthy hosts thus was born
the Green Lantern Court the issue with
this is that along the way the Green
Lantern's had basically encountered
Atrocitus the first of the red lanterns
and Atrocitus by you know looking into
the future by casting different
prophecies had basically learned of
something called the prophecy of
blackest night' this idea that all these
Lantern cores would rise all these
Lantern cores would go to war some
unknown dark force would come into
existence and then basically wipe out
all emotion in the universe and then
wipe everything out and all life would
basically cease to exist because of the
fact that this basically created a
scenario where the guardians of the
universe had to face the idea that their
lives their existence were not under
their control they in turn chose to
ignore it now we're a couple of the
guardians ganthet and sayd
where they were basically banished from
the guardians of the universe for
refusing to ignore the prophecy of
blackest night one of them the scarred
Guardian actually began the process of
ensuring the blackest night came into
existence and so that's where a lot of
this stuff ends up happening it's
basically gathering all these different
things together these different
resources pushing the guardian
is operating behind the scenes moving
them in the direction of ensuring that
this War of the Lantern cores this war
of light begins to take place and so
what our story does is it actually
transitions over to a guy named William
hand now this is one of the reasons why
it is that I said that with the whole
Geoff Johns run on green lantern that he
would just kind of introduce a character
and this character would pop up in a
little bit of a story over here and then
they'd never be seen or heard from again
for like a year and a half this is one
of those instances William hand was a
guy who popped up in the secret origin
of Hal Jordan and all we knew about him
at the time was that he was just
obsessed with the concept of death now
the idea was that with the secret origin
of Hal Jordan designed to go back and
reach how Hal Jordan the Green Lantern's
origin story from the time he first
appeared in DC Comics all the way up to
the modern day we ended up finding out
that William hand was there when Hal
Jordan first became the Green Lantern
he's simply been operating behind the
scenes the entire time the question
became what is this harbinger of the
Black Lantern Corps what was he doing
during this time and that's why this is
so cool this tale of the Black Lantern
because it's basically the life and
times of the first Black Lantern the
person who would basically uh sure in
this core that would try to eliminate
all things in existence now what we know
about William Han is again referencing
this a little bit of history with his
character he was obsessed with death
what this tells us is how obsessed with
death he was it wasn't like one day he
just said you know what I think death is
cool instead it was a gradual thing it
was him dealing with his family who were
essentially morticians or at least his
father who was a mortician watching the
things that he did and becoming enamored
by the idea of death in the same way
that people will fire up a video game
and say this is the greatest video game
I've ever played and I'm gonna play it
all the time because it's the absolute
best William hand loved death the exact
same way he was enamored by it he
studied it he always wanted to be
surrounded by it he was uncomfortable
with living normal human beings instead
he was more comfortable when he was
surrounded by the dead the results of
this is that back when Atrocitus you
know the the harbinger of the Red
Lantern Corps first popped up on earth
again Atrocitus had looked to the future
and seen that a guy named William Han
was going to bring about this blackest
night this war of light and so the
result is that Atrocitus sought to
eliminate William hand
this led to the intervention of both
Sinestro and Hal Jordan the newest
introduction to the Green Lantern Corps
working together and then taking trosset
us out following this William hand just
remained behind the scenes for the most
part the weapon of Atrocitus this you
know device it was able to channel
Greenland Green Lantern energy was
essentially left behind and in using
this what ended up happening is William
Han just sort of became this guy that
was going to the process of trying to
implement death everywhere he went he
simply just obsessed with a concept of
killing things now of course this leads
to him donning his costume basically
becoming black hand this is of course
references all the way back to the old
school Green Lantern stories where black
hand was very much a minor villain of
Hal Jordan this expands on that and it
basically says this is the road that
William hand took that led him to
basically becoming - the harbinger of
the Black Lantern Corps now the other
half of this is that because William
hand was operating behind the scenes the
entire time that Hal Jordan was the
Green Lantern he was privy to all these
different changes so when Jon Stewart
first popped up as the second Green
Lantern on earth
followed by Guy Gardner followed by Kyle
Rayner the events of emerald highlight
when he basically began to channel all
this fear became a host for the living
embodiment of fear in the form of
parallax wiped out all the Green
Lantern's these are all the things that
William hand was seeing he was watching
them happen the idea here was that he
had seen more and more superheroes die
more and more often the issue at this is
that each time for the most part they
kept coming back
so characters like digger Harkness Ted
Kord Maxwell Lord Himself who was killed
by Wonder Woman in response for shooting
Ted Kord had all these different things
that existed out there the death of Jon
Jones
Aquaman or at least the perceived death
of Aquaman you know all these different
things have gone into the idea that as
far as William hand is concerned what is
dead should stay dead
in his mind death is really a living
entity people who die should not be
allowed to return and in his mind with
Superman having quote-unquote died only
to basically be healed with Hal Jordan
quote-unquote dying only to come back
after being taken by the specter with
Kilowog with Bart Allen with Barry Allen
dying and then coming back to life
during Final Crisis again these are all
the ideas that William Han believes that
death has been cheated and so because of
this
and his goal is to basically find a way
to begin the process of giving death the
people it rightfully deserves this
coincides with his desire to just
inflict as much death as he possibly
can't to kill anything he can where he
can't and some of the first victims are
basically his family he goes through and
begins killing each member of his family
ultimately turning this device on
himself now the reason why this matters
is because when this happens it's
basically him fully handing himself over
to necron the entity of death and that's
really the way it works with these
different Lantern cores right I mean you
know for example if we take the Red
Lanterns it was really Atrocitus just
experiencing absolute rage over the fact
that his family had been obliterated by
the Manhunters the result was that as he
began to channel this rage as he looked
into the future and saw he was going to
be the harbinger of the Red Lantern
Corps He fulfilled that prophecy by
creating the Red Lantern Corps by
forcing the creation of a Red Lantern
power battery and then a Red Lantern
central power battery it was just
working through the emotion of rage
every single Corps always has that one
person that creates it and that person
goes through all these different steps
and all these different processes this
journey of sorts that ultimately leads
to the formation of that court with
William hand it's a little bit different
it's not like the scar Guardian shows up
basically spews this black Lantern ring
out which in turn attaches itself to
William hand and says you are going to
be my harbinger for the Black Lantern
Corps it's not like this scarred
Guardian started spitting out all these
Black Lantern rings and they all just
started going around because and the
question is who would they go to this is
basically the core of death and so the
only thing that really can be done here
is for William hand to begin the process
of resurrecting the dead and that's why
this is so cool is because at this point
we switch over to the perspective of the
death of Batman through the eyes of
Barry Allen the flash and Hal Jordan
himself now this is told from a variety
of different ways but when it came to
the death of Batman it's really more of
a misnomer Batman being hit by the Omega
beams of of Darkseid during Final Crisis
was basically this idea that they the DC
could essentially remove Batman from the
landscape for a time and then tell a
story of his eventual return what ended
up happening as Batman was just time
displaced that's all it was he was
thrown back to the very early days of
humanity
that was really it now of course this
was DC's attempt to basically set the
stage to go back and retell this
grandiose story for the origin of Batman
in the end it didn't matter because they
rebooted like two years later but the
whole idea here is that from the
perspective of Hal Jordan and Barry
Allen they don't know the Batman's all
the way back at the early days of
humanity as far as they're aware Batman
is dead now the other half of this is
that how Jordan begins talking about the
idea of how people respond to those
individuals who have been killed keep in
mind when Barry Allen died he died as a
hero he died basically saving the
multiverse you know and so there were
all these different responses to his
death all these different ideas that
people were coming back people were
saying oh man we have to celebrate the
life and times of Barry Allen for Hal
Jordan it wasn't that way I mean we
talked about this a little bit ago how
Jordan's life has been mired in just
controversy and struggle and strife but
as parallax he didn't die a hero nobody
looked at Hal Jordan said aw man that's
so sad
this once-great Green Lantern had a fall
from grace but we should remember him
the way he used to be not at all people
looked at him and said he's a bad guy he
is a villain he died a coward's death he
went out like a madman and that is the
legacy that's been haunting Hal Jordan
ever since remember with the whole run
of Geoff Johns Green Lantern when he
originally started killing all those
original Green Lantern's of course we
ended up finding out that some survived
The Lost lanterns as they're referred to
but the idea is they look at him and say
you betrayed us you tried to kill us
Batman himself you know despite the fact
that Batman in Hal Jordan were extremely
close friends when Hal Jordan became a
villain and sort of calling himself
parallax he betrayed the trust of Batman
and that was a trust that was broken
that took time to reform and so again
this is the whole you know legacy that
he's dealing with this is the aftermath
of the events that he's coping with at
the same time Batman was only one of the
more recent deaths encounter books
William hands goal is to essentially
begin resurrecting all these guys make
them his Lantern core in an effort to
start killing off all these different
beings it exists all throughout the
universe itself so again this leads into
a massive calamity which ultimately goes
into brightest day and it goes into you
know the whole like white lanterns and
all kinds of cool stuff and this is when
we start getting into the cool stories
oh my god Rob core man let me tell y'all
something this story do block his night
man this story is so good if God was
right in Green Lantern right now is what
it would look like right now he's one of
the best stories that I've ever seen
ever read in the history of counter
books do this story so amazing so
blackest night is as much like a soft
reboot as it is just like this amazing
epic because remember blackest night
basically focuses on the resurrection of
like all these dead superheroes kind of
a resurrection is sort of a weird
situation but blackest night really is
like this next stage of Jeff John's run
on Green Lantern and this has been a
long time coming keep in mind the Green
Lantern I guess landscape as is
progressed over the course of the entire
you know series that we've done so far
which we cover every Sunday the idea is
that it all started with like Sinestro
Corps war right like thousand Estero
formerly a Green Lantern abused his
powers he was banished he found a yellow
lantern it basically had a yellow
Lantern ring created for himself and
then formed his own core this led as a
direct conflict between the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps but the
idea was that this was really rooted in
the character of Aven sewer Aven sewer
was a Green Lantern he was the one who
died on earth and gave his ring to Hal
Jordan but Aven soar had been told of
the prophecy of blackest night' by a
being named Atrocitus Atrocitus that
looked into the future and saw that
there was going to be this massive war
of light and the black lanterns would
rise and extinguish all life across the
universe but the guardians of the
universe
saw this is fear-mongering Atrocitus was
a guy who made the Red Lantern Corps and
so the idea was that because Green
Lantern's have to overcome fear in order
to be able to use their powers that this
was all just a tactic used by Atrocitus
for the purpose of weakening Adam sors
so he could be defeated because of this
almost none of the Guardians took it
seriously the only two who did were
ganthet and sayd and in order to protect
themselves from the prophecy of blackest
night' and to ensure that there would be
some sort of way to win they formed the
Blue Lantern Corps and so at that point
it was just a waiting game we had the
blue lanterns there we had the Indigo
tribe this super mysterious Lantern
Corps that we didn't really know
anything about you had the star
sapphires who were a lantern court
rooted in love you had the green
lanterns you had the Sinestro Corps that
was kind of out there somewhere and then
you had the red lanterns and that was
really about it I mean it was just okay
now we're just having these stories and
we're just waiting until blackest night
half
but all of this really stems from a guy
named William hand this guy is a dude
who was just obsessed with death but
because all the different lanterns are
Lantern cores that exist out there have
entities basically these living
embodiments of their respective emotions
the living embodiment of death is a
being named Necron and this is the
person that William hand basically
warships but the idea here is that this
all initially kicks off with William
hand literally going to the grave of
Bruce Wayne and taking his skull now
this comes immediately out of Final
Crisis and we have not covered Final
Crisis just because of the fact that
that story is an exercise in the
absolute befuddle meant and mind
boggling of why a person would write a
story like that but the long and short
of Bruce Wayne's involvement in Final
Crisis is that the villain Darkseid one
of the new gods had basically sought to
dominate all things in existence by
using the anti-life equation at the end
of the story Bruce Wayne fired a killing
shot at Darkseid Darkseid uses Omega
sanctions which should have just killed
Bruce Wayne instead he was actually
time-displaced which is one of the roles
this story serves to basically show us
that Bruce Wayne's not dead but everyone
believes he's dead and so because of
this of course he's been buried at Wayne
Manor so on and so forth and the idea is
that in the face of Bruce Wayne being
believed to have been dead we end up
having all these black lantern rings
which are just sent out across the
entire universe now what this does is
this switches over to Coast City and
this is kind of a cool thing because
again all this really goes back to like
how Jordan becoming parallax those of
you guys who are new to the whole Green
Lantern landscape Coast City plays a
really significant role not just because
of its location but because of the place
that it has within the realm of the
superhero community Coast City is the
basically the main base of operations
the main city for Hal Jordan is really
like his home more or less and the idea
was that back in the 1990's DC wanted to
get rid of Hal Jordan they wanted to
remove him from the equation and replace
him with a new Green Lantern so what DC
did is they wrote a story called Emerald
Twilight an emerald Twilight came out of
the death of Superman we had Superman
dying at the hands of doomsday we had
four new supermen who popped up on the
scene one of these was a guy named
cyborg and the idea was at cyborg
superman alongside a villain named
Mongol attacked KO city and destroyed it
the result was that when how
came back from a mission in space he
found everything he knew and loved
completely obliterated what this did is
it left him open to exposure to fear
basically he lost his ability to
overcome fear for a temporary amount of
time but in that small window it allowed
the living embodiment of fear named
parallax to enter Hal Jordan now the
idea of parallax entering Hal Jordan and
possessing him
that was a Geoff Johns change that was
not something that we learned until I
2006 2007 but the idea wasn't at the
time it was basically how Jordan just
becoming a bad guy and so what ended up
happening here is how Jordan basically
just laid waste to the entirety of the
Green Lantern Corps it was a massacre
like nothing we'd ever seen before
he ended up destroying all the Green
Lantern's he killed all the guardians of
the universe except for one and so what
ended up happening is that with Hal
Jordan basically mainlining the
willpower emotion and mainlining fear he
basically became God just started
calling himself parallax now what this
did is it led to the last remaining
guardian of the universe ganthet
traveling to earth and giving Kyle
Rayner a ring and that's where Kyle
Rayner ended up becoming the Green
Lantern that's how his whole origin
story comes into play but the idea here
is that because eco city was being
rebuilt as part of Geoff Johns run on
the Green Lantern stories what this does
is it brings us to its conclusion which
is to say Coast City has been fixed now
Coast City has been repaired people are
starting to move back it's this whole
revelation that Coast City is the place
to be now and it's a celebration of a
multitude of different things this also
comes on the holiday that's basically
been created as a result of Superman's
death when Superman died at the hands of
doomsday back in the 1990's the super
heroes of the DC Universe basically
christened that as a holiday when he
came back it was the day of Superman's
death a day of Superman's return so on
and so forth and so that became like
this national event but what ends up
happening is we get this sort of rundown
about all these different instances of
people who have died people who have
loved others who have lost the ones they
loved it's really kind of this day to
remember all the most important things
in life but to also honor those
individuals who have died and so again
as touching on these various characters
these various individuals who have
played roles in the realm of the
superhero community one of the more
notable instances is Aquaman Arthur
curry following the event of Infinite
Crisis basically the story that brought
the multi-verse back after
nurse DCE had a series of comics called
52 but they also had something called
the missing year and the idea was that
after Infinite Crisis Aquaman was gone
nobody knew where he was now the
intention of DC at the time was to
actually kill him was to have him dead
and gone forever but Aquaman
despite the legacy of being the guy that
caught on quote talks to fish fans still
loved him and fans wanted him to return
so we ended up making his debut what
this ends up doing is it still leaves
out there the idea that Aquaman is dead
not only that it actually solidifies the
belief that Aquaman's dead in the sense
met with Mara and with Garth basically
you know Aqualad more or less talking
about the the death of Aquaman and
overlooking his grave and so on and so
forth he actually ends up reimagined
he's one of the one of these other
people who pops up during the whole
event of blackest night which is to say
a person who has a black Lantern ring
now he's not the first person we see I
just kind of throw it in there because
we were talking about Aquaman anyway but
we actually end up doing is picking up
with Barry Allen again one of the big
revelations that came during Final
Crisis is that where Barry Allen was
believed to have died during crisis on
Infinite Earths and it only ever really
popped up once in a while in terms of
like a flashback or something along
those lines
what Final Crisis revealed and what
flash rebirth the original flash rebirth
revealed was at Barry Allen never died
Barry Allen merged with the Speed Force
and in the 20-some odd years or even
longer than that the 25 years vetted
that he had basically been missing from
DC Comics in truth he'd actually been in
the Speed Force outrunning death
constantly and so because of that during
Final Crisis Barry Allen re-emerged and
he was one of the coolest moments ever
because it's like Jay Garrick and I
think Wally West and like one other
person they're there you know and like a
portal opens up and it's just like Jay
Wally
one and like Barry Allen comes running
out of this portal and like everybody
and it was like holy cow
who is hilarious because if you go and
look at message boards back in 2009
people were just like watch people were
freaking out because Barry Allen
returned and it was one of the crazy
things but the other half of this is
that with Barry Allen being alive one
thing to keep in mind is that his return
basically comes after 25 years of being
absent and so literally how Jordan
catches him up on everyone who's died
over the last 25 years whether it was a
day ago or it was 25 years ago and this
includes a
lot of people it includes John Jones
Martian Manhunter Black Canary da
Aquaman it includes all these characters
Barry had fought alongside during his
years when he was a superhero and so
learning all of this will we also end up
finding out is that the Justice League
is not without honor the Justice League
actually ended up taking the corpses of
people whose identities as villains were
known and basically keeping them in the
Hall of Justice giving them an honorable
burial now the other half of this really
deals with what's going on out in space
which is to say the war of light
remember while all this is taking place
on earth all the other Lantern cores are
out fighting basically all the Green
Lantern's that exist out there with the
exception of like Hal Jordan on earth
they're all out in space they're all
fighting against the zamarons the star
sapphires the Sinestro Corps I mean
they're basically engaged in this
massive war of light and that's what the
guardians begin to comment on none of
these guys believed it was real none of
these guys believed that the war of
light was going to happen none of them
believed the blackest night prophecy was
actually going to come to fruition but
faced with this war of light faced with
the Green Lantern's fighting the red
lanterns fighting the blue lanterns
fighting the Indigo's fighting the star
sapphires fighting the Sinestro Corps
faced with all of that the guardians of
the universe now have to come to accept
the fact that the war of light is
happening the problem with this is that
it's preparing for an earthquake after
the earthquakes already started it's too
late and so at this point they're
literally just under damage control but
what little hope they have in trying to
stave off this war of lighter at the
very least trying to come out on the
winning side is almost completely swept
away when the scarred Guardian reveals
her allegiance to the black Lantern's
remember after the events of Sinestro
Corps war there were these small things
that happened here and there in the
Green Lantern story that all led into
this all led into this blackest night
run this is essentially the first strike
in this instance one of the Guardians is
killed by the scarred Guardian the rest
are imprisoned and the shield around OA
is brought down and what this does is it
allows these black Lantern rings to just
start flying and just begin bonding
themselves to all these dead Green
Lantern's and resurrecting them if you
guys haven't grasped it by now all hell
is breaking loose this is crazy Katie
bar the door the it's man man this is
why I say the story so good
Jeff John what do you have to write such
damn good stories Oh like things are
just popping off and that's what people
are basically coming to coming to
realize here kyle rayner Kilowog Guy
Gardner these guys who are like you know
members of the Green Lantern Corps out
there in space Barry Allen Hal Jordan
they're coming to the realization that
all these dead superheroes are coming
back as black Lantern's and that's
what's so cool about this because what
is up happening is we basically have all
this pandemonium taking place now
another thing to keep in mind other
characters of elongated man and soo
didney Sudanese character really gained
like her biggest moment in DC Comics
when she was killed by Jean Loring
during the events of identity crisis now
that's a story that we haven't covered
yet just because it's so controversial
it's a pretty dark story it's it's
pretty pretty crazy but it basically
deals with like mind wiping different
things like that but the idea here is
that elongated man essentially died
during countdown to Final Crisis I think
it was and so they've been gone for
quite some time soo did me having
already been killed and so this is
basically bringing those characters back
for kind of a short stent now they have
like pretty significant roles in the
hearts and minds of a lot of DC fans
everywhere a lot of DC fans are just
like yeah man Ralph did me I don't know
what he did outside of identity crisis
but I remember that I remember soo
deeply during identity crisis but I
don't know anything about her outside of
that which is fine because a lot of
people latch on to characters during
particular stories the idea here is that
this is essentially different people
trying to deal with the emergence of
these black Lantern's all at the same
time now with Aquaman with him popping
up as a Black Lantern this basically
goes into him killing off a multitude of
his soldiers attempting to take Meera as
his queen and then using his powers to
literally just kill almost everybody
else around him now of course this also
introduces the death of Garth but again
this is when we started getting into
this whole soft reboot thing the reason
for this is because of the fact that
with like elongated man if su did me for
example they'd end up showing up and
they kill Hawkman and they kill Hawk
woman and then they basically turn him
into black Lantern's but the idea was
for DC to essentially kill off all these
different characters and then say okay
with all these characters quote-unquote
being dead here's the ones that were
gonna bring back and so it was
essentially kind of a soft reboot you
know is better than simply having like
Hawkman walked down the road and gets
shot in the face and they're like the
death of Hawkman like it was a lot more
interesting than
so it kept things interesting it kept
them going smoothly but it also allowed
DC to get rid of characters that either
weren't popular or their stories weren't
selling or what-have-you but one of the
other things that we end up learning is
that these characters who were dead and
are being quote-unquote resurrected are
not their real cells and that actually
comes from a guy named Boston bran
now dead man is a guy who basically just
goes around inhabiting bodies he takes
over people he's part of that whole DC
vertigo mysticism magic he's part of all
that that storyline that goes over there
but the reason why this matters is
because dead man actually shows up as a
black lantern while simultaneously
existing as as normal self and so what
this means is that these black Lantern's
that are running around as superheroes
are not actually resurrected superheroes
instead they're basically duplicates but
the reason why this matters and the
reason why then showing up the way they
do is pause for concern is because in
order for them to basically begin rising
in order for them to essentially charge
the central power battery to 100% they
need people who are in various emotional
states and then they need to consume
their hearts and so what this does is
with them emerging with these various
superheroes faced with teammates friends
former lovers who are believed to have
been resurrected from the dead as evil
lanterns then suddenly it starts putting
them in this emotional state of fear or
rage or something along those lines and
because they're so charged with
emotional energy they take their hearts
they consume them and the entire Black
Lantern Corps is even more empowered
because of it now one of the biggest
moments of the Black Lantern Corps comes
in the form of the spectre remember the
spectres basically the representation of
God's vengeance but the spectre is one
of these characters and DC Comics who's
about as close as we get to DC's
iteration of like the cosmic entities
remember Marvel deals with things like
the representation of the universe how
long it takes from the time the universe
was made to the time that it ends that
timespan
they have like cosmic entities for that
they have cosmic entities that represent
the entirety of the universe they have
cosmic entities that represent all these
different things DC plays it a little
more realistic DC plays it as okay so
there's the presence there's basically
God and the DC Universe then there's
like Lucifer Morningstar basically Satan
but the reason why this matters is
because these characters these higher
pantheon of characters in DC are largely
considered to be so astronaut
we powerful that they're well beyond the
capabilities of any traditional
superhero but then in the face of these
black lanterns emerging these rings
bonding themselves to people one of the
Rings takes over and corrupts the
specter and so what this means is that
the power of the Black Lantern rings is
basically of the highest echelon of the
highest order that no one can withstand
the power of these ranks the reason why
this matters is because this is Geoff
Johns basically saying no one's safe
there's no safe haven but he does
provide one exception the only exception
he provides to this are individuals who
died and are at peace and so what it
basically seems to indicate is that the
only individuals who can be resurrected
or who can basically be copied by the
Black Lantern rings are individuals who
died under grudging circumstances people
who died unwillingly and so because that
it allows them to basically be copied to
re-emerge and it just sends things
spiraling almost out of control now of
course this also brings into fray the
superheroes doing the best they can
because again when you're faced with
power like this it's not a matter of
overcoming them by traditional means
it's a matter of just running like hell
and hoping you survive another day and
in this instance this is brought to us
by virtue of Barry Allen and Hal Jordan
remember Barry Allen is a chemist as
much as he has the flash and it's not
very often that you see those two things
go hand in hand you usually see that
aspect of his personality when he's
doing his normal job as a forensic
investigator but his cool seeing him in
this instance because as we know with
Martian Manhunter his biggest weakness
is fired and so it makes sense to Barry
Allen to basically start dousing him
surrounding him with chemicals and then
when Hal Jordan throws a car in and the
car blows up everything catches the
flame that Martian Manhunter would be
weakened the problem with this is that
that's not the case
instead Jon Jones Martian Manhunter
emerges just like he did before and so
what this does is again this sets the
stage by saying that the traditional
weakness of superheroes as they existed
before they became black Lantern's is
not really effective here instead you
have to defeat them as black Lantern's
as opposed to how they used to be not
from here we actually end up
transitioning to a guy named Jason rush
and to a girl named I guess it's Jenny
it's spelled really weird it's like geh
n EE or something like that but the idea
here is that this was DC's attempt to
basically reinvigorate the whole concept
a firestorm remember Ronnie Raymond is
firestorm had been that way for quite
some time and it's one of the most
popular iterations of his character and
this instance is actually Jason and this
girl Ginny we're gonna go ahead and call
her that who basically inhabit the same
body or at least who will become the
firestorm concept the issue with this is
that Jason had basically merged with
several people before this so it was
literally DC grabbing him and saying
okay Jason Rusch will be the main
firestorm person and then we'll grab
whoever house and see which person fans
liked the most the issue was that Ginny
was not really a character fans enjoyed
too much so they actually end up killing
her off in this story but again one of
the other things that we end up learning
is that the the Black Lantern range
cannot just be removed by traditional
means instead the rings actually grow
roots down into the person they are part
and parcel so try to remove the ring is
almost impossible because the ring will
come back that person is part of the
Black Lantern Corps and they will stay
that way unless a tried and true means
of taking them down can actually be
found and so because of this you know
with Jason Rusch with Jenny basically
going through the investigating as best
they can
of course we end up finding out that
they were summoned to the Hall of
Justice by Mira herself the wife of
Aquaman and that's really where this
story begins to hit home because what
this is is just escaping it's them just
fleeing for their lives now of course
this also coincides with the arrival of
the Indigo tribe now remember the Indigo
tribe are very mysterious but one of the
reasons why the Indigo tribal are so
powerful is because they can tap into
and manipulate other Lantern cores and
so in this instance indigo one the leer
of the Indigo tribe is actually able to
separate one of the black lanterns from
their rings using a combination of the
Indigo tribes power and the Green
Lantern's power so again what this does
is it actually tells everybody else
who's there about being able to defeat
the Black Lanterns basically comes
through combining powers together and
trying to take them out but that's a
stopgap measure all it's really going to
do is solve things temporarily what they
need is a tried and true measure of
bringing the black lanterns down and the
cool thing about this IFS geoff johns
teases it to us Jeff John actually tells
us something called the white light and
what he basically says is that in the
beginning of all things do was simply
just white light there was just white
that's all there was but eventually the
darkness essentially you know overrule
the light it took over and it led to the
creation of all life the emotional
spectrum and
so on and the white light fragmented and
so what this means is that the white
Lantern ring as most people know by now
is effectively a combination of all the
Lantern rings you know brought together
at least one of each Lantern ring
combined into one and that of course
will be the means by which they end up
winning I mean I don't mind throwing
that out there because this story came
out like eight years ago so most people
know what's going on with regards to
this but again you know at this point
it's just a matter of trying to get away
it's just a matter of trying to win now
of course this leads to Ginny basically
being killed off and again fans didn't
really enjoy her too much she was
mysterious DC never really expanded on
her and so because of that they ended up
killing her character off and it leaves
a landscape open for Jason to merge with
someone else and so in the face of all
this because of the fact that the black
Lantern's are continuing to rise in
prominence the question becomes where's
Superman where's Wonder Woman where are
these superheroes that were most
familiar with who we would think would
at the very least be here in the midst
of this conflict well we're not
immediately told and in fact there's
actually tie-ins for those characters
which we are going to cover but in the
face of recognizing that a combination
of green lantern energy among other
forms of energy can temporarily defeat
individual members of the black
Lantern's it then becomes basically
Barry Allen running around broadcasting
this information to everyone who's out
there and so this is when we find out
that Wonder Woman is fighting these
black Lantern's then all these different
characters who exist out there the
Titans the Teen Titans that they're all
facing off against these black Lantern's
doing the best they can not only that is
also this revelation that individuals
like dr. fate are black Lantern's dr.
fate of course again being the
predecessor to Marvel's Doctor Strange
but again these are all great moments
Power Girl Allen Scott the Green Lantern
of Earth to all these characters are
facing off against the best they can to
hold off against unstoppable odds and so
as this section the video begins to wind
down
what is up happening is the Black
Lantern central power battery is
teleported to coast city by the scarred
Guardian and what we end up finding out
is that with the central power battery
charged at 100% what it does is it
allows the living embodiment of death
the entity known as nekron to enter into
the earthly plane to enter into the main
DC Universe and make his presence known
while simultaneously resurrecting every
single person who's ever died in Co City
and dragging them into the Black Lantern
Corps okay so a few things first and
foremost I had intended to finish Green
Lantern blackest night by the time
Halloween ended but then I was going
through and I was like we haven't really
done anything with like the Green
Lantern tie-in or the Green Lantern
Corps now the funny thing about this is
that the the Green Lantern mythos is
just largely those two titles that's
really all it is they cross over in
terms of like big events like Sinestro
Corps war different things like that but
usually they tell two distinctly
different stories from two distinctly
different perspectives the issue I ran
into is we wouldn't be able to have the
entirety of blackest night done by the
time we finished all the tie ins if we
kept it every Sunday when Halloween
rolls around so we're doing it in our DC
days we get three Green Lantern videos a
week I guess three blackest night videos
a week rather so if you've loved like
it's night you're gonna be hyped we're
still gonna keep our DC rebirth stuff so
we're gonna have to double upload which
works because like for the next couple
weeks it'll basically be Green Lantern
blackest night and dark nights metal on
the DC days so ah I'm sure a lot of the
guys will be over the moon in terms of
the stuff that we're gonna be doing but
again
blackest night really comes out of the
events of Sinestro Corps war that's
really all this is and that's why
Sinestro Corps war is so important one
of the things that we learned over the
course of geoff johns entire run of
Green Lantern is that there was this
prophecy called the prophecy of blackest
night and the idea was that over the
course of the existence of the universe
these different cores would come into
existence the red lanterns would come
into existence and the blue lanterns
were come into existence and the star
sapphires and the you know indigo tribe
and all that kind of stuff all these
lanterns would rise to prominence most
all of them would be super obscure and
almost nobody would know about them save
for the Green Lantern's themselves and
in the Sinestro Corps when they rose to
power during the events of Sinestro
Corps war but the prophecy of blackest
night basically stated that there would
be this war of light among all the
lantern cores and the result is that the
black lanterns would basically rise and
then eliminate all life in the universe
and that's exactly what's happening the
guardians of the universe some of those
powerful beings in existence knew about
the prophecy of blackest night they
believed the prophecy of blackest night
was fear mongering it was an attempt to
strip Green Lantern's of their power by
instilling in them
belief that the universe would come to
an end and all these Lantern cores would
rise and in doing so green lanterns
would cease to be as powerful as they
once were paving the way for almost any
number of other villains to rise to
power now because of that when Sinestro
Corps war popped off and in the
aftermath of Sinestro Corps war once we
got into Infinite Crisis and those
storylines and once the black Lantern's
started to rise the guardians of the
universe kind of looked around and said
well I guess they were right
the problem is that this created a rift
of sorts because a couple of the
guardians named ganthet and sayd always
believed the prophecy was gonna come
into existence and so in order to
prepare for it they created the blue
lantern course and the blue lantern just
kind of existed out there the fact
remains here that in the presence of all
these black lantern rings when we began
covering blackest night we basically did
issues one through four and then stopped
and started doing tie-ins the reason for
that is because everything that we're
covering right now in terms of these
tie-ins really until I say otherwise
this is all taking place during the
first four issues of blackest night the
other half of this is that almost
everybody is encountering this in their
own way at the outset the Green Lantern
Corps is encountering all this stuff at
the outset Hal Jordan and those guys are
on earth they're encountering it Jon
Stewart is actually just sort of
pondering the nature of the mistakes
that he's made when it came to the
planet of zhanchi now we talked about
this before between 1988 and 1989 DC
published a story called cosmic Odyssey
it was a four part series and it was
weird it was a really really weird story
written by jim Starlin but it basically
detailed this idea that there was just
some being called an t life more or less
that it split itself into four parts and
it had gone to four different planets
but the idea was that jon stewart was a
relatively new and pretty reckless Green
Lantern when he was younger and the
result was that he teamed up with
Martian Manhunter to try to find a way
to basically keep zhanchi from being
destroyed doing to the fact that if two
of these planets were obliterated the
universe would be destroyed in its
entirety he basically screwed up ran
headlong into it found this giant bomb
in the middle of the planet was too late
to save it and everybody on the planet
died now the funny thing about Jon
Stewart is that he is basically a Green
Lantern
that did not initially rise to any real
significant measure of popularity until
Justice League came out in 2001 he was
introduced thirty years earlier in 1971
he basically served as a backup
character throughout the entirety of the
Green Lantern run running
the way up through Amol Twilight he had
involvement in all those stories you are
our crisis and time and so on and so
forth up until green lantern rebirth
which is where he began to increase in
popularity even more among comic book
readers just because of the fact that
his popularity and justice Lee the
cartoon show and then Green Lantern
rebirth basically set him to one of the
higher echelons of characters but the
idea here is that because of the fact
that zan she was a planet that he
obliterated what this does is it
basically tells us that there is no
limit to what it is that the Black
Lantern rings can resurrect they can
recreate anything zhanchi itself is
resurrected as an entire planet to serve
the purpose of operating alongside the
black Lantern's now this will eventually
go into like Jon Stewart's own sub story
that will lead into the main blackest
night story and actually see him do some
pretty cool stuff but what we end up
doing here is we switch over to xamarin
where the home of the star sapphires as
well as the Sinestro Corps now one thing
to keep in mind is in the aftermath of
the Sinestro Corps war there were a
couple of things that had taken place
the first is that Sinestro himself had
basically been defeated and captured and
the result was that the Green Lantern's
were intent on taking him back to OA to
be put on trial the problem with this
was that in the middle of it all the
Green Lantern's were ambushed by a
combination of the Red Lanterns those
who you know survived the Sinestro Corps
war and even the blue lanterns
themselves and it led into this great
big huge conflict which I have a video
on that you can check out down in the
description this is stuff that I suggest
you check out the Green Lantern playlist
just to get the full you know
explanation of it but the idea was that
Atrocitus the leader of the red lanterns
so he wanted to obliterate all lanterns
in existence wanted to just get rid of
them all in their entirety the idea was
that this led into a series of
skirmishes that took place between the
the Sinestro Corps the red lanterns the
blue lanterns the green lanterns in
addition to all this one of the members
of the Sinestro Corps named Amon Sewer
the son of AB and Sewer who first gave
Hal Jordan his Green Lantern payments or
had basically eliminated the entire
family of one of the Green Lantern's and
the result was that this lanterns friend
had basically discovered what was going
on and in her wrath killed Amon sore
despite the fact that he was basically
surrendering the result was that Lyra
herself was ousted from the Green
Lantern's and in her rage was given a
Red Lantern ring and then that led into
the whole skirmish of the Green Lantern
showing up now Sinestro being captured
so on and so forth in an effort to
basically
to turn lyra away from being a Red
Lantern because of the fact that she was
one of the original Green Lantern's faul
Sinestro had actually killed her while
Howard was trying to reason with her Hal
Jordan eventually became a Red Lantern
different things like that but this all
basically goes towards this idea that
the Sinestro Corps itself was
experiencing what amounted to a civil
war in the sense that you had thousand
Estero who had finally been captured by
the Green Lantern's and was being held
prisoner while that was going on a
villain named mongrel who is by and
large a strong if not stronger than
Superman depending on what stories
you're reading was given a yellow
Lantern ring himself and then basically
co-opted leadership of the Sinestro
Corps and took it over in sinestro's
absence and so what you basically had
were members of the Sinestro Corps who
were loyal to and those who were
loyal to Sinestro the result was that
when everything popped off and when
everything started going to pot and it
all started going awry Sinestro made his
escape he was out he grabbed those who
were faithful and then tracked down the
star sapphires which leads us here now
the reason why he's here for these star
sapphires is because of the fact that
these star sapphires are based on love
and so what they did is they took a
whole bunch of members of the Sinestro
Corps and they started putting them in
these crystals of sorts that would
basically convert them to star sapphires
Sinestro showing up here simply serves
the purpose of grabbing you know his
members of the Sinestro Corps bringing
them back and then eventually going back
killing Mongol and then taking back over
his Sinestro Corps again with this idea
of the Red Lanterns transitioning back
to Islam this is still the aftermath of
all this stuff Lyra is still dead the
Green Lantern's are still trying to make
their escape or dealing with the Red
Lanterns themselves and then suddenly
Black Lantern rings just start
descending on everyone so again that's
why there's so much back and forth here
that's why there's so much jumping
around is because we're talking about a
war across the universe with these black
lantern rings seemingly showing up out
of nowhere now the other half of this is
that star sapphires effectively have the
ability to tap into the emotions of
people by way of love and an attempt
that's made by Carol Ferris who was
formerly a lover of Hal Jordan the first
star sapphire and then ultimately
rechristened with the star sapphire Jim
again is that she had actually encased
Sinestro in this crystal of love more or
less and tried to convert him her tried
to begin the process of converting him
now under normal circumstances what
happens is that if a person is not
powerful enough when they're encased in
crystal they'll basically just kind of
begin
shut down go into a comatose state and
the conversion process will begin but
they can still resist it they can refute
the conversion this is designed to show
us how powerful Sinestro is that were
the other members of the Sinestro Corps
are trying to resist this conversion and
it's taking quite a lot of time for it
to happen as soon as he's put into a
crystallized by Carol Farris he
immediately shatters out of it because
it's basically this idea that he is in a
lot of ways though walking talking
living embodiment of fear now the
problem with this is that in the middle
of their skirmish much like the skirmish
between the Red Lanterns and the Green
Lantern's and all that stuff we're
basically met with the arrival of the
Black Lanterns and so again that's why I
say all this takes place over the course
of the first four issues is because this
is basically all these different groups
in the middle of their ongoing conflicts
basically in the middle of this war of
light and then suddenly the black
lanterns start appearing out of nowhere
the other half of this is the orange
lantern Larfleeze who's basically kind
of an outlier when it comes to all the
lantern cores that exist in DC Comics
they effectively have this governing
rule in the sense that only those who
are able to overcome great fear can
become Green Lantern's only those who
are basically able to manipulate fear
and use that fear to empower themselves
can become Sinestro Corps members so on
and so forth Larfleeze is not like any
of the other course Larfleeze is the
orange lantern of greed of avarice and
so the idea is that he has the whole of
the Lantern Corps power to himself which
makes him insane in terms of the kind of
things that he can do but the idea here
is that because the blue lanterns were
so intriguing to Larfleeze when the
opportunity arose which we had covered
previously for him to basically capture
the blue lanterns when he was introduced
to the idea that they exist he basically
took all of his constructs and just sent
them all directly to the blue lanterns
themselves now that's the inherent
difference between Larfleeze as an
orange lantern and everybody else all
the other Lantern cores have multiple
members the blue lanterns the red
lanterns the green lanterns yellow
lanterns but with Larfleeze
his core is consists of constructs
anyone he's ever killed becomes a
construct they become something for him
to control the problem with this is that
again with Larfleeze having killed so
many people his base of operations is a
giant graveyard it means when Black
Lantern rings start descending under
Larfleeze base of operations it's
nothing
but black lanterns that start rising
everywhere it's just him by himself but
his power is extreme and will actually
find out just how powerful he is in the
next few videos or so but the idea is
that again this is why the blue lanterns
are fighting the orange lanterns is
because it's the constructs of Larfleeze
trying to overpower the blue lanterns
and then take the rings from them so he
can just hoard the Rings for himself
it's just this giant treasure trove you
know that he essentially keeps around
and so the idea here is that with this
war of light going on with the blank
lanterns rising themselves what it does
is it begins to shift its focus to the
idea of the Indigo tribe now Before we
jump into that what we actually end up
doing is picking up with a Green Lantern
core line of stories which is to say all
the other green lanterns that are out
there - Hal Jordan and the idea here is
that this picks up in the aftermath of a
story called emerald eclipse now emerald
eclipse we didn't cover we didn't really
have a reason to you just because the
entire basis of the story we could
explain later on within the span of five
or six minutes but the whole idea of
emerald Eclipse is it was basically DC
finally finding a way to deal with the
character of so DeMott so those of you
guys who don't know so to me odd is
what's called a daksa might and daksa
mites live on the planet dax um
somewhere along the line in DC's history
some Kryptonians basically left the
planet of Krypton and then took up
residence on Daxton over time they
basically became xenophobic the result
is that as time progressed if somebody
from another another planet or something
like that showed up on their home they
would basically be destroyed or
something along those lines so DeMott
hails from that race of people much like
Superman if he's exposed to a Yellow Sun
he'll develop Superman powers the idea
was that as a child he had come across
what amounted to a spacefaring explorer
crash landing on his homeworld and his
actual existence was kept hidden away
from everybody just so that they
wouldn't you know freak out when he was
there but through this Explorer so
tomate learned about the greater
universe about the Green Lantern Corps
and all these different races that exist
out there and someone is so forth
the problem was that when this Explorer
was discovered he was basically taken
killed and stuffed by the dachshunds
themselves this created an absolute
hatred for his own race and their
xenophobic views at the hands of sodam
yacht in response to this when he was
given the opportunity to become a Green
Lantern he immediately took it now he
became significant in the Green Lantern
mythos for two reasons the first is
because it was believed
if someone like Superman ever became a
Green Lantern they'd be the most
powerful Lantern in existence because
it's basically the powers of Superman
combined with the powers of a lantern
ring and so that would be hitherto
almost unchecked powers the other half
of this is that he was destined to
become the new I on when DC originally
launched the events of emeralds fly
light and Azure our crisis and time how
Jordan became possessed by parallax all
that kind of good stuff he eliminated
almost the entirety of the Green Lantern
Corps how Rayner basically became a
being called ion which basically allowed
him to house the entity in the sense
that he was basically able to
single-handedly resurrect the entirety
of the Green Lantern's that's what the
ion entity is should all the Green
Lantern's be killed the ion can bring
them all back he can basically bring
back the guardians and the central power
battery and all that kind of stuff the
whole idea is that because sodam yacht
was so powerful during the events of
mongol running the Sinestro Corps he
basically invaded the planet of daksa
sodam yacht intervened and in the midst
of it all basically took the red Sun or
flew himself into the red Sun and then
used his own energies and converted it
into a yellow Sun gave all of his people
Superman powers and they fought off the
Sinestro Corps and that's basically it
that's the gist of it but the idea is
that he was believed to have been left
for dead he was believed to have died
now he didn't and he'll come back during
the events of brightest day but at the
time he was believed to have been gone
and it allowed DC to put him on the back
burner but while there isn't a whole lot
of meat and potatoes to the Green
Lantern Corps story what this basically
does or at least in terms of this story
is it deals with the idea that with
these Black Lantern rings descending on
all these different people everybody's
having to deal with it in their own way
for the character of Kyle Rayner he
basically sees this sort of
reincarnation of the character Jade the
daughter of the Green Lantern Alan Scott
who how Rayner had been in love with and
who had ultimately died because of the
fact that Jade alongside almost all the
other girlfriends that he's had have all
perished in tragic circumstances it's a
haunting factor of Kyle Rayner that's
one of the reasons why he never really
gets into relationships or if he does
it's tedious because for him he's always
afraid the girlfriend he has is gonna
get quote-unquote stuffed in a
refrigerator that's the big concern that
goes on in his mind when it comes to
other people the other half of this is
it actually shows how sadistic the Black
Lanterns are in the sense that they
actually bust into a infirmary for the
most part where all these Green
Lantern's are healing from various
injuries the conflicts they've been in
and they
literally go in and just start tearing
out their hearts I mean it's pretty
intense in terms of what it is that they
end up doing here but again this is the
first appearance of the black lantern
rings to a vast majority of the Green
Lantern Corps so again it's pretty cool
in terms of how it all unfolds but Jemmy
back to Sinestro Julie back to the Black
Lantern so the fact that these black
Lantern's are basically emerging two of
the most important ones come in the form
of Amon sword and Aaron sewer now Aaron
soar was at one time the only person
that Sinestro had actually looked and
cirrhotic not to is the daughter of
Aaron Sora and Sinestro himself we
learned that during the events of I want
to say it was when the Red Lanterns
captured Sinestro himself but the idea
here is that facing off against these
black Lantern's keep in mind the black
Lantern's themselves basically feed on a
motion the whole idea is that they are
basically emotional batteries in the
sense that they force all these
different people they come across to
feel fear or rage whatever the case may
be and those emotions charge up that
person's heart and when that person's
heart is charged the black Lantern's
take their hearts consume them and all
that energy feeds the central power
battery the reason why that's important
is because when the central power
battery is at 100% the entity that
represents the Black Lantern Corps is
Necron himself and it will allow him to
enter the realm of the living that's why
this is a huge deal and so again that's
why this is so huge is because in the
middle of this all the Indigo tribe
finally steps in and the whole goal here
is for them to essentially be the voice
of reason the voice of logic and they
will be the ones who will basically come
together and say we have to unite the
Lantern cores against the blackest night
we cannot let them battle because if we
do then what this will do is it will
basically live up to the prophecy and so
with that in mind the Indigo tribe
indigo won at least the leader of the
Indigo tribe basically grabs Sinestro
and takes them directly to Mongol
because the whole idea here is to
eliminate Mongol and reunite the
Sinestro Corps because they need every
single living member of every single
Lantern Corps and more to defeat the
black Lantern's it's a coming together
of every living being in existence to
fight off against the black Lantern's
and have it come to a head in a massive
battle Thal Sinestro is just one with
his own Lantern Corps he knows how to
use it in a way that nobody else does
Mongol is just this heavy hitter
he's just this Slugger that's really all
it is he's really really smart and he's
very capable but he's not a master of
the Sinestro Corps Sinestro actually
overpowers and eliminates Mangal
right off the bat and so what this does
is it basically leads him to this idea
that we're going to see the return of
the Sinestro Corps and we're eventually
going to see a continued to call to arms
all these Lantern cores coming together
to join the Earth's superheroes and face
off against the Black Lantern Corps
which will ultimately lead into the rise
of the white Lantern's okay so
continuing our discussions on blackest
night at this point we pick up with the
second part and this focuses partly on
the Green Lantern Corps and the second
half on the Green Lantern title itself
again much like we did in the previous
video now in the last video we had
basically dealt with this idea that
there were two things happening in the
universe at the same time I mean the
Black Lantern rings are basically these
rings that attach themselves to those
who have been deceased and they
resurrect them for the purpose of
emotionally charging other individuals
so that when those individuals and
hearts are just filled with all
different types of emotions the Black
Lantern takes their heart consumes it
and it feeds their central power battery
charging it up to 100% now the idea here
is that in the last video we basically
mentioned that the Black Lantern rings
basically spreading throughout the
universe was a massive calamity because
what it meant is that individuals who
had died across the universe were being
resurrected no matter what planet they
were on and we even saw entire planets
being resurrected by the black lantern
wings now of course all this goes
towards the entity of necron which is to
say in the DC universe when it comes to
the emotional spectrum you've got
entities that represent those spectrums
they're not really gods they're really
more just kind of like avatars and so
necron is kind of this living embodiment
of death so to speak but the idea here
is that the goal of the black Lantern's
is to basically charge the central power
battery to 100% so that it will
basically open a gateway and allow
Necron to enter the living realm and all
this is important because of the fact
that this feeds into the war of light it
feeds into the rise of the black
Lantern's all these Lantern cores go
into war against one another while
that's happening the black Lantern's
rising to prominence ultimately
eliminating all life in existence and
then assuring and this basically
blackest night this eternal darkness and
the universe and so with the Green
Lantern Corps this again focuses on
basically everybody except for Hal
Jordan the main Bri
and quote-unquote in the DC universe and
so we basically end up picking up with
like sonic not to you and these
characters and we had talked about how
the black Lantern's
were really sadistic because they would
basically kill anybody in this instance
it was the black Lantern's going to the
infirmary of the Green Lantern Corps and
then with those individuals who were
effectively injured or who were
basically unable to defend themselves
the black Lantern's would terrify them
and when their hearts were charged they
would just seize them and take their
hearts out of their bodies they were
basically killing helpless people so
it's pretty insane in terms of how that
unfolds but again that becomes
significant because it's like classic
zombie infection the more zombies there
are the more zombies they're become just
because the black Lantern's once they
kill someone a Black Lantern ring
suddenly bonds to that person and the
numbers bolster even further and so
that's what this is this is a
continuation of the idea that the Green
Lantern Corps is basically coming to the
realization that the dead are rising in
the form of black Lantern's and the goal
is to get as many people out there as
they possibly can the problem with this
is that each individual member at least
the most prominent members of the Green
Lantern's are dealing with the black
Lantern's in their own individual way
now this is something that happens
across the board for cirrhotic not to
she's basically the the top medic the
top doctor of the Green Lantern Corps
and so to see individuals being killed
and then turned into black Lantern's is
her own way of basically having to deal
with it being confronted by the Black
Lantern concept now this means that the
black Lantern's themselves will fill her
heart with emotion with rage with fear
with willpower so on and so forth and
they'll try to take her out as well but
what had happened over the course of the
Green Lantern Corps line of stories by
Peter samasya as he began focusing on
this idea that a kind of affection was
brewing between ceramic natsu and Kyle
Rayner as a Green Lantern now in all
honesty this just made good sense it's
basically this idea that a lot of the
girlfriends of Kyle Rayner were his were
like you know heroic or they were very
virtuous but with cirrhotic not - she
basically possesses all those character
traits she's headstrong she's brave
she's got the drive war accounts she's
got ambition her goal is to be one of
the greatest Green Lantern's and so it
was basically Peter J Tomasi coming
along and saying we're going to
introduce a love interest between Kyle
Rayner and cirrhotic not to you but
she's not gonna go out the same way as
everybody else the cool thing about this
is that with Kyle raiders most recent
girlfriend a girl by the name of Jade
who was basically the daughter of the
Green Lantern Alan Scott
what happened is that she essentially
sacrificed her life in order to save
Kyle Rayner also imbued him with
something called the star heart which is
basically a version of the Green Lantern
energy from a different reality and the
idea here was that it helped to bolster
the powers of Colorado which wards him
being ion we talked about that in a
previous video but the long and short of
this is that Jade had basically been
resurrected by a Black Lantern ring and
much like all the black lanterns that
we've seen so far the goal is emotional
manipulation feed on their emotional
state whatever relationship they have
charged their hearts with energy and
then take their heart when it's filled
with emotion Jade had initially appeared
to Kyle Rayner as hey it's okay that I I
pass you know that's that's the way
things go but we can be together again
and this kind of hope you know this blue
lantern energy of hope filled kyle
rayner it was also real power and was
also the belief that maybe things can
work out but it was really Callaway noir
putting on a ruse that he was playing
along with Jade to understand the
motivations of what the black Lantern's
were looking for and that's when Kyle
Rayner came to the realization the black
Lantern's are looking to charge people's
hearts with emotion and then consume
them now in the middle of all this
because Jade had such an emotional and
psychological impact on Kyle Rayner it
takes the intervention of ceramic not to
just sort of snap POW in or out
completely in the sense that he's aware
of what it is at Jade's doing but his
heart can't help but feel that maybe
they can be together again now of course
again so rynek not you has no stake in
Jade she doesn't know Jade she's never
met Jake and so cirrhotic not - is the
voice of reason here she's the one that
essentially kind of defies at all and
jumps into the fray now the other half
of this are characters like Kilowog
right for Kilowog he doesn't really have
a whole lot of emotional attachments to
other people that are out there for him
he's the drill sergeant of the Green
Lantern Corps
he's very militaristic in that fashion
and so for him it's honor and Duty above
all else but as the drill sergeant for
the Green Lantern every single Green
Lantern that dies feels like it's the
fault of Kilowog and that's what the
black Lantern's feed on in his case is
this idea all these different black
Lantern's out here there were formerly
Green Lantern's who died in the line of
duty
they wouldn't have died if you done your
job like you were supposed to and that's
what fills them with rage because
remember no matter what any of these
Green Lantern Corps members feel the
black Lantern's will feed on it but one
of the darkest moments comes from out of
this and we basically find out that the
children of cribb have all come back as
black Lantern's now Cribb was a
character who
I believe originally introduced in the
Sinestro Corps war but crib was
basically this weird alien entity that
essentially went on this pattern of
killing Green Lantern's and then taking
their children and making the children
her own now she wasn't like abusing them
or anything she would just take them
whisk them off to some planet somewhere
and say you are now my children but the
idea is that for whatever reason that
hasn't been explained yet these kids
have all basically died now this can
largely be due to the AI be attributed
to the fact that crib was the only one
taking care of these kids
and with crib basically having been
captured by the Green Lantern's and then
allowed to go with these zamarons the
star sapphires these kids are just kind
of left to their own devices and
ultimately ended up just perishing
according to the environment but the
problem is that in the middle of all
this we end up having the arrival of one
of the indigo lanterns now again when it
comes to the black lanterns the only way
to truly defeat them
is to blast them with just a massive
amount of just bright energy basically
white light and the way in which you can
pull that off is by combining rings
together or something along those lines
by blasting them with a massive amount
of light energy what it does is it
creates a feedback in the ring basically
causes the ring to essentially overload
and the result is that this feedback
resonates throughout the black lantern
themselves and they said we just explode
but what this does you know with the
arrival of these kids with the arrival
of the Indigo tribes showing up and
basically helping the Green Lantern's to
stave off the Black Lantern Corps we
switch our focus to the red lanterns now
again we talked about this in the last
video in the sense that the red lanterns
were basically dealing with the
aftermath of the Green Lantern's trying
to retrieve one of their own who had
previously perished and in the middle of
this whole conflict you know what the
green lanterns being the only ones
really left there the black lantern
rings started descending on everybody
and what happens is four of the five
inversions are basically resurrected now
the fifth inversion is Atrocitus himself
the person who created the Red Lantern
Corps but to provide a little bit of
history for those of you guys who are
watching this video for the first time
the first thing I would suggest is
checking out the origin of the red
lanterns that way you'll fully
understand who the five inversions are
but the long and short of this is that
before the green lanterns were ever
created by the guardians of the universe
the guardians of the universe had
created the Manhunters and the
Manhunters are basically just robots and
the belief of the guardians is that
because the robots only do what they're
told they're the perfect form to
basically police the universe to make
sure that there is no
threats with regards to people trying to
obliterate planets for anything along
those lines the problem is that the the
Manhunters malfunction and will actually
find out later on down the line that it
was one of the Guardians themselves that
caused it to happen but the idea is that
what the Manhunter is basically going
awry they traveled to Sector 666 and
basically killed everyone and so what
ended up happening is the survivors of
sector 666 these five inversions came
together in their hatred for the
guardians of the universe and began the
process of plotting and trying to find a
way to eliminate the Guardians in their
entirety along with the newly formed
Green Lantern Corps and so we're
Atrocitus was one of the five inversions
and he basically seen a vision of the
future with regards to what's actually
happening right now what he in turn did
is killed the other four inversions and
then created the Red Lantern Corps and
so that's why these inversions are
resurrecting is because these are the
people that Atrocitus killed and so in
this instance with the four inversions
popping up his black Lantern's Atrocitus
is fearless and doesn't care because
he's so full with rage because rage is
the one governing force of his life his
heart was already charged with full
emotion but the caveat to this and
remember when it comes to the red
lanterns when they're given a Red
Lantern ring it replaces their heart and
so where the black Lantern's attack
trosset us for the purpose of taking his
heart and consuming it his heart will
inevitably regrow now this has both a
benefit and a drawback the benefit is
that they can't kill Atrocitus by
tearing his heart out which means the
red lanterns cannot be killed by the
black lanterns and the red lanterns
themselves cannot become black lanterns
unless of course the ring is taken away
the drawback to this is they are
basically an infinite source of emotion
as long as they keep like red lanterns
prisoner like lanterns could literally
just repeatedly tear out their hearts
and consume them until they charge the
central power battery that's why this
threat of the black lanterns has to be
dealt with as fast as humanly possible
but in this instance because Atrocitus
is basically the living embodiment of
rage the black lanterns don't stand a
chance you know him blasting them with
massive amounts of energy and so on and
so forth again causes these black
lanterns to come crashing down
and so what this does is basically
transition to this third part of the
story this last little bit where we
basically pick up with Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern we pick up with Sinestro
and we pick up with the Indigo tribe as
well as the Star Sapphire this comes out
of the idea that with Sinestro having
been in
prisoned by the green lanterns after the
event of the Sinestro Corps war it
allowed a villain by the name of mongrel
one of the most notable enemies in DC
and someone who's basically equal to
Superman in strength in a lot of ways to
rise to power after receiving a yellow
lantern ring and then basically take
over the Sinestro Corps himself and so
what this did is once thousand estra was
free from his imprisonment in the midst
of the rise of the black Lantern's he
went out he basically tried to seize
back control of his Sinestro Corps and
the first stop was xamarin the home of
the star sapphires because the star
sapphires had taken a number of the
Sinestro Corps and tried to convert them
into star sapphires and so because of
that Sinestro arriving is also met with
the Indigo tribe you know indigo one who
had basically snatched Hal Jordan from
Earth brought him over to xamarin in an
effort to basically start uniting the
different cores and again that's the
basis of the Indigo tribe the Indigo
tribe is a Lantern Corps of compassion
but they're also the Lantern Corps of
reason and logic and so this basically
puts us where we are right now with
regards to a little bit of infighting in
the sense that we have Hal Jordan and
Sinestro bickering among one another but
it's basically this idea that we have to
begin working together we have to
function as a cohesive unit because if
we don't this war of light will consume
us all and the black Lantern's will just
bring about the end of all things in the
universe so ultimately what this does is
again this Hicks up a little bit with
regards to the blue lanterns and the
orange lanterns remember the orange
lanterns are basically the Lantern Corps
of greed of avarice but instead of
having an actual core it's basically
just Larfleeze himself in the sense that
his core consists of constructs but the
blue lanterns are basically a lantern
core based on hope it's the idea that no
matter how bad things get there's always
a way to overcome things and so the
power of the blue lanterns can only
really stand some measure when it's
accompanied by the powers of the Green
Lantern's the Green Lantern's are kind
of the foundation that power is the Blue
Lantern Corps and that's why in this
instance despite the fact that the blue
lanterns are largely considered to be
the most powerful they're really
struggling against the orange lanterns
because there's no no Green Lantern's
there to bolster their own power but
this changes when indigo one brings Hal
Jordan and Sinestro and Star Sapphire
directly to where it is the blue
lanterns are at because again the green
lanterns bolster the Blue Lantern power
and the Blue Lantern rings can
supercharge the Green Lantern ring so
they're designed to basically work
together but this allows the blue
lanterns the power they
need facing against Larfleeze the
problem is that in the middle of all
this all the orange constructs vanish
and the reason for this is because
Larfleeze recalled them all to himself
because of the fact that again the black
lantern range descended on Larfleeze his
base of operations and began bonding
themselves to all these people Larfleeze
had killed in his greed and in his
hubris and so with this in mind the
Larfleeze basically begins to panic and
basically begins to run off but is met
by the arrival of Atrocitus who
basically shows up having defeated all
four inversions and the black lanterns
on his own home planet with the
intention of not only seizing the orange
lantern ring for himself but using it
with his own abilities because what it
would do is would bolster the power of
the red lanterns in terms of the fact
that he's able to use two different
rings at the same time so again
Atrocitus his motivation is to still
take out all the different Lantern cores
to basically ensure that the guard is
the university' feeted and so on and so
forth he's not yet been recruited to the
cause of all the other lanterns he's not
yet been told here's everything that's
going on he's aware of the prophecy of
blackest night he's aware of what it
means but he doesn't really seem to
grasp the idea that if the prophecy of
blackest night rises to its full
fruition everybody will die including
him and the red lanterns themselves okay
so jumping back into blackest night
again this is when everything begins to
change and this is cool because for
those of you guys who are following or
who saw our very first blackest night
video which was basically the main
blackest night story issues one through
four this finally brings us to the point
whereby the central power battery is
completely charged and this begins the
process of allowing Necron the living
embodiment of death in the DC Universe
to begin moving in to the realm of
reality and initially it's not like this
right off the bat it's this continued
fight against all these different
members of the Black Lantern Corps now
remember when it comes to the Indigo
tribe because they're the logical and
the regional one are reasonable ones
they're the ones who immediately picked
up the clues right off the bat on how to
defeat the black Lantern's is basically
just a massive amount of light now the
way in which this comes about is with
one of the members of the Indigo tribe
the second-in-command speaking with one
of the other Green Lantern's and while
they're facing off against all these you
know these black Lantern's the questions
asked how is it that we're able to kill
him the way we are and the response of
the member of the Indigo tribe is to
simply say I can combine my light with
your life and we can in turn destroy the
Black Lantern race
the issue with this is that it has to be
concentrated it cannot be a wide burst
it cannot be a scattershot and that's
what's established here because the
question asked by the Green Lantern at
hand is well why don't we just like fly
up into the air and just broadcast our
light everywhere and the reason why is
because they're only dealing with so
much light they only have so much to go
around and so the response is if they
were to fly up into the atmosphere and
if they were to use this what they would
basically do is blanket the black
lanterns in light but it wouldn't be
concentrated enough to actually destroy
the Rings but all that amounts to a
zero-sum anyway because in the middle of
this conflict the black lanterns stop
and then they all take off with the
command to devour will do to the fact
that the central power battery for the
black lanterns is fully charged at 100%
now what this does is it gives us the
other half of the equation where the
first part of this which we talked about
in the last video was basically
consuming emotionally charged hearts
after forcing individuals to feel all
these different emotions when their
loved ones came back as black Lantern's
the other half is to eliminate anybody
who can basically be a threat because
remember if the black lanterns were to
fight these green lanterns and try to
kill them there's always going to be
more Green Lantern's River that's the
basis of the Green Lantern Corps that
whenever a Green Lantern dies it's ring
immediately goes out and seeks a new
host but to beat them to the punch what
they do is try to strip the Green
Lantern's of their source of energy they
go directly after this central power
battery remove its connection to the
emotional spectrum and in turn no matter
how many green lantern rings there are
out there they'll simply just cease
functioning and the other half of this
scenario is the Green Lantern's facing
off with it the absolute best they can
stimming this flow of black Lantern's
because essentially every black lantern
in the vicinity on the planet of OA and
even some from other parts of the cosmos
are all travelling directly to destroy
the central power battery but I mean
look at this look at the sheer number of
black lanterns here that's not all of
them and so hopefully that gives you
some indication as to how many black
lanterns are floating out there in the
cosmos how many black lanterns are
fighting however many other beings exist
out there and so in this instance where
they basically try to pull the central
power battery the efforts of the Green
Lantern's are virtual or virtually
non-existent there's really nothing they
can do at the same time the
Lantern Shoah the Red Lanterns showing
up is to help the Green Lantern's defeat
the Black Lanterns but again because of
the fact that the black Black Lantern
reins need concentrated beams of light
in order to basically be destroyed in
the end the hatred from the red lanterns
means they're just mindless beasts
attacking things and so that's all they
know all they know is to go to the Black
Lanterns and attack the Black Lanterns
well for all the good it does they might
as well be you know beating a metal wall
with a wooden baseball bat it's not
gonna do them any good and with all
these black lanterns coming together and
pulling out the central power battery
kyle rayner is the one who saves the day
because what kyle rayner does is travel
and basically grab the source of the
Alpha lanterns power kind of like this
this center floor of the Central Valley
central power battery basically yank it
out take it to where the black lanterns
are at and detonated he effectively
seems to kill himself in the explosion
but it does let off this massive amount
of green lantern energy and then that
happens it does begin the process of
taking out a lot of these black lanterns
but not all of them some of these black
lanterns are still there and so in this
instance when Kyle Rayner dies Guy
Gardner loses it I mean absolutely
snapped and in this moment where he's so
angry he suddenly bonded with a Red
Lantern ring now remember when it comes
to the red lanterns you don't get to
choose to be one you don't get to say
like yes I'm down for being a Red
Lantern no the ring finds you and just
forces itself onto you as a red lantern
literally just losing all semblance of
self control he's wielding a Red Lantern
ring and a Green Lantern ring it allows
him to achieve the very goal that the
Red Lantern and the Green Lantern's were
trying to accomplish by merging the
lights together and allowing him to cut
an absolute swath through the Black
Lantern Corps I mean he literally starts
ripping these guys to pieces bit by bit
now in the middle of all this is
cirrhotic not to the medic of the of the
Green Lantern Corps who is in love with
Kyle Rayner trying to bring him back
because he's not quite dead yet he's
basically in the process of dying his
heart slowing down and all that kind of
good stuff but the other half is that
he's constantly being beset by black
lantern rings they're constantly driving
to bond themselves to him and resurrect
him as a black lantern now of course the
Indigo tried coming to the aid helps a
little bit but at the end of the day
they're you're talking about thousands
of rings that are going to start making
their way to where Kyle Rayner is and
that's the craziness of this situation
is because it's the
actions of Guy Gardner as a red and
green lantern destroying the Black
Lantern Corps they're making things even
more dangerous for Kyle Rayner and so
this is when we start to get the other
half of the equation of all these
different tribes beginning to come
together in the sense that the star
sapphires being so imbued with love of
helping others feel loved that the ring
goes off whenever somebody is feeling
heartbroken and in this instance one of
the star sapphires her ring goes off
when cirrhotic not too basically begins
to lose hope in the idea that she'll be
able to resurrect Kyle Rayner that she's
heartbroken because she may lose the man
she loves and in that moment this star
sapphire comes flying to the rescue
through their ability to manipulate the
emotional spectrum aspect of love they
can help bring people back they are as
much healers as they are individuals who
spread love now again they're very
parasitic in terms of how they're how
their Lantern Corps works that's why
they're not these Saints is because
they're just as inclined to encase you
in Crystal and convert you to a star
sapphire as they are to actually help
you out reencountering her back by
passing the love of ceramic not too to
kyle rayner himself serves the purpose
of allowing the story to continue on and
one is up happening here is Kyle Rayner
gets his ring back and goes forward as a
Green Lantern helping to cast off the
rest of these black Lantern's along with
the question being asked how are they
going to get the ring off of Guy Gardner
with Guy garner being probably one of
the most important Green Lantern's
because of how amazing he is the goal is
to find a Blue Lantern
that can remove the ring from him now
moving into the last little tidbit of
our tie-ins before we actually jump back
into the main Green Lantern story itself
we pick up with what's probably the
coolest tie in which is everybody versus
the Red Lanterns it's the orange
lanterns and the blue lanterns and the
star sapphires and the Indigo tribe and
the Green Lantern's against Atrocitus
it's really cool what this does is it
picks up in the aftermath of Atrocitus
chasing after the orange lantern
Larfleeze and so the whole idea is that
he actually seizes the orange lantern
battery from Larfleeze himself and then
in turn just becomes obsessed with greed
and it's interesting because we don't
really get you know usually get to see
things like that but in the middle of
this whole thing he's met with Sinestro
and Saint Walker of the blue lanterns
and Hal droid of the Green Lantern's and
Carol
the star sapphires and indigo one and
where there's a little bit of bickering
and a little bit of arguing between all
these different things once it all
settles down we actually end up learning
a few things that took place now a lot
of this is a misunderstanding we're
looking at something in a
compartmentalized fashion as opposed to
the overarching thing in the sense that
Sinestro starts making the case well you
know you Hal Jordan were the one who
went to the planet went to the Vega
system where Larfleeze resided would
violated the treaty between the
Guardians and Larfleeze but you did it
at the request of the Guardians and you
showed up on ismo at the home of the Red
Lanterns because you were trying to
rescue me because the Guardians wanted
you to you were doing all these things
that gaudiest wanted you to do and you
were the one who set the war of light in
motion which is kind of true to a degree
but not necessarily the war of light was
not set off by any one thing it was a
litany of different things all happening
at the same time it all actually
culminated with Sinestro himself in the
sense that Sinestro had basically waged
war against the Green Lantern's
in the Sinestro Corps war the Guardians
allowed the Green Lantern's to start
killing people and in this instance it
basically started off as these small
little potshots here in their Lyra a
Green Lantern who killed a member of the
Sinestro Corps wasn't she what when she
wasn't supposed to it was Mongol taking
over the Sinestro Corps in the absence
of Sinestro himself and then using the
Corps to basically implement his own
campaigns which led to the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps
fighting each other again
it was Larfleeze basically believing
that the treaty between himself and the
Guardians had been violated when the
Green Lantern's led by Hal Jordan showed
up there the Blue Lantern Corps being
created by ganthet and sayd it was the
rise of the black Lantern's it was all
these things that came together and
culminated in the war of light so in
truth if it's anybody's fault it's
everyone's fault because everybody had
everybody had a hand in it somehow but
the coolest thing about this is that it
really asks the question if we had to
define an actual person who was
responsible you know which person would
that be and the argument presented here
in the story is it is actually Atrocitus
because Atrocitus was the one who
originally saw the prophecy of blackest
night and realized what was going to
happen with the war of light who taunted
ab and Sewer the Green Lantern they gave
Hal Jordan his ring and it was Evan
Sewer who basically told everybody about
the prophecy of blackest night and the
war of light so maybe that's the case
but again that's the nature of how this
thing plays out and it's the nature of
what Geoff Johns is kind of pointing out
here that in any one particular scenario
barring a
person going in and then just committing
a series of linear acts it's never any
one particular person's fault when it
comes to this there's equal blame all
around everybody's screwed up equally
that's basically the scenario here again
the cool thing about this is that people
try to talk reason to what's going on
with Atrocitus the fact that he's so
driven by rage and he's so angry but
notice this there is somewhat of a
measure of respect among these various
members of the lantern cores and the
guardians of the universe ganthet and
sayd because they realize the stakes are
much higher in their own individual
petty squabbles I mean looking at
someone like thousand estro in his mind
it's his way or the highway there's the
way he wants things to be and then
there's everybody else who's wrong but
in this scenario
he's bargaining he's telling look like
hey Atrocitus I will work with you if
you ally less and will destroy the Green
Lantern Corps number they have a mutual
hatred for the Green Lantern's it's
largely saying yeah sure I mean I'll
join too but like I want my own guardian
like I want a guardian of the universe
for myself that's just largely he's
being greedy cuz that's his whole thing
he's just a super greedy guy but these
people who would never work together are
effectively finding common ground if for
no other reason than self-preservation
the black Lantern's have United the
lantern course together and their desire
to not die it's a selfish motivation but
selfish is not inherently an evil thing
in this particular story it's cool
because it's people coming together for
a singular cause as people coming
together and basically working together
and that's the beauty of the Indigo
tribes because remember the Indigo tribe
is the voice of reason there's a voice
of logic through the ones that do not
allow themselves to get caught up in
petty squabbles and so what happens as
indigo one actually takes all the
members here from these Lantern cores
and teleports them to yzma to the home
of Atrocitus and this is important
because Atrocitus actually begins to
feel some measure of compassion is him
sitting down and finding common ground
with the other Lantern course because in
the mind of Atrocitus he's not
necessarily a villain by and large when
it comes to comic books we usually
define villains in a subjective way
which means that we don't all define
villains the exact same way but for the
most part I define villains as people
who do bad things because they can not
because there's any real motivation to
it but because they're just like I can
commit this crime so I'm going to commit
this crime like I just want a lot of
money that's how I would define a
villain Atrocitus as a red lantern looks
to destroy
the green lanterns and the guardians of
the universe but notice this it's not
because he can
he doesn't say like I want to eliminate
the guardians of the universe and the
green lanterns because I just don't like
the fact of the guardians are blue and
small and I just don't like the Green
Lantern's because I hate the color green
it's nothing like that
it's basically him saying my people were
wiped out because the guardians of the
universe were foolish and they were
arrogant and they believed they could
police the universe with robots and
those robots destroyed everything I knew
and loved and I will go to the ends of
the earth I will go to the end of time I
will do whatever I have to to eliminate
the guardians of the universe not
because I hate them but because I want
to make sure they cannot keep making
stupid decisions that will result in the
loss of life of innocent people and so
while his motivations are extreme he's
not really a villain he's not really a
bad guy in the traditional sense and
that's what's so cool about this is it
takes the character as we perceive him
and dumps him on his head it literally
just flips the script on the whole thing
and so in the end in this recognition
Atrocitus basically allies himself with
this Lantern cornices fine
I don't want innocent life to be wiped
out by the black lanterns I believe the
innocent life should continue to thrive
if the black lanterns are the immediate
threat to innocent people then I will do
my best to keep them alive I will do my
best to save those innocent lives but as
soon as this is done as soon as this is
over and as soon as this threat is
quelled
you can bet all the money in your
pockets then I'm coming for you I'm
coming for you as the guardians of the
universe and I'm coming for you as a
Green Lantern's and woe betide you if
anything doesn't get in my way I will
literally bring everything you know and
love crashing down so basically is this
idea that once we're done with blackest
night it's business as usual and
business is good
now the whole idea is that every single
member of the Lantern Corps I guess
every every part of the emotional
spectrum which is to say all the lantern
cores have an entity
necron is like the emotional aspect of
death if death could be an emotion the
whole idea here is that when it came to
the various superheroes who have died
over the years one of the big questions
people had is if these superheroes have
died how were they alive now well the
great thing about this is that Geoff
Johns comes along and he says okay
none of these superheroes actually died
and this conversation this whole you
know taunting by William hand and Necron
is so on what we end up learning is that
Barry Allen was supposed to have died
during the
of crisis on Infinite Earths when he
broke down on a molecular level he was
supposed to go to the afterlife he was
supposed to be dead nekron got in their
way and stopped him from dying and sent
them back and that's how they lived now
the other half of this is remember the
only real spacefaring force that's
capable of dealing with these black
Lantern's as a Green Lantern Corps and
like we covered in previous videos
they're dealing with the black Lantern's
off in space and so it's basically just
the Earth's superheroes so we have like
the Teen Titans and the Justice League
and all these different superhero groups
that come together to try to face off
against Necron and all these black
Lantern's remember this is almost like a
losing war right like these guys it's a
stopgap measure that's all it is it's
them jumping in and trying to destroy
these black lantern rings because
remember the only way a Black Lantern
ring can truly be destroyed is if a
massive amount of light from multiple
sources is basically just thrown at
these black lantern ranges so you'd have
to have somebody like dr. light who can
manipulate light you have to have like
multiple cores coming together and
firing all their rings at the same time
and channeling those energies in order
to destroy them and the whole idea of
channeling their energies comes to bear
for the various leaders of the lantern
cores to basically put their energies
together into the black lantern central
power battery remember the black lantern
central power battery like all the other
central power batteries is basically
where the black Lantern's get their
power from so the whole idea is if they
destroy the central power battery it'll
do two things the first is it'll
basically deactivate all the black
lantern links and the second is it'll
send necron back to his own round
whoever it was that he came from the
problem is it doesn't work because it's
so much power and so much energy it's
almost impossible to do and so what is
up happening here and probably one of
the greatest moments in the history of
comics these rings start flying out one
of them says Bruce Wayne of Earth rise
so Bruce Wayne like Bruce Wayne
Bruce Wayne's dead and ends up coming
back and is one of the coolest things
now remember this is not really Bruce
Wayne like it's not really the essence
of Bruce Wayne the spirit of Bruce Wayne
it's his body it's basically the black
lantern rings reconstituting Bruce
Wayne's body and then using it as a
vector but when it comes to Bruce Wayne
he is probably one of the single most
important characters in all of the DC
landscape for a bunch of different
reasons one of the first reasons is
because of the fact that everyone is
tethered to him and that's why he was
brought back but the whole idea is that
whether they
Rustom whether they don't trust him
whether they love him what if they hate
him everybody in some former fashion is
connected emotionally to Bruce Wayne and
so because of this using this emotional
tether of Bruce Wayne in the shock of
the moment all of these guys are
basically bonded with Black Lantern
rings and we end up with the Black
Lantern Justice League
the only exception of this is Hal Jordan
and Barry Allen at this point we switch
over to Jon Stewart now Jon Stewart is
one of those Green Lantern's where he
basically achieved the height of his
popularity during the Justice League
cartoon show he breach aids that show by
like 30 years but he was just one of
those Green Lantern's out there and in
the end despite the fact that he was
introduced back to him despite the fact
that he was amazing it didn't much
matter because the Green Lantern titles
weren't selling anyway but with the
Justice League cartoon show he was the
only Green Lantern on that show as it
was a way to just bolster a bolster him
up say hey you want a Green Lantern you
get Jon Stewart and nobody else but in
this instance one of the things to
remember and one of the things we talked
about before was Jon Stewart in his
younger days John Stehr was a member of
the Marines and then eventually he
became a Green Lantern but when he first
became a Green Lantern he was headstrong
he was arrogant this came to bear with a
planet called zhanchi this this was
basically a planet that was part of this
really weird storyline but the idea is
that there was a bomb in the middle of
the planet and instead of basically
keeping it safe instead of keeping the
bomb from detonating Jon Stewart flew in
and tried to basically defuse it the
result is that the bomb went off killed
the planet and killed everybody on it
this is weighed on Jon Stewart's mind
ever since and that's the cool thing
about this has always been a background
of his character and so him being here
he's the only one on this Black Lantern
version of zhanchi that this planet that
was reconstituted by the Black Lantern
rings alongside everybody who was killed
but the cool thing about this is Jon
Stewart is not a guy to be trifled with
Jon Stewart is an absolute beast he
literally just starts creating machine
gun constructs and he unleashes holy
hell on every single one of these black
lanters it is pretty amazing but
ultimately jon stewart also recognizes
that if he were to continue fighting
this battle on his own he would
assuredly die and if he's taken down by
one of the black Lantern's it'll just
add to their existing ranks now jimmy
back to earth because i know you guys
are really interested in earth the Black
Lantern Justice League versus all these
different superheroes or at least
whatever's left is actually pretty
impressive because they're all basically
fighting their own personal demons
no accident that each of these members
is being you know being pitted against
somebody who they are most familiar with
for example when Hal Jordan became
parallax during the old Emerald Twilight
stories him facing off against Superman
and defeating him has always been
considered an insult to Superman himself
and the rest of the superhero community
now large this was because of the fact
that Hal Jordan as parallax was trying
to obliterate the entirety of the
universe but it was still pretty cool
but Barry Allen grabbing Hal Jordan and
racing a couple seconds into the future
basically allows or at least it means
these black lantern trains that are
chasing them are basically gone because
while they are a couple seconds ahead at
the end of the day in the present moment
right then and there they're gone while
all this is happening Jon Stewart is
racing the earth with an army of all
these black Lantern's behind him so all
these things are basically crescendoing
down into this moment when everybody
basically coalesce is on earth everybody
shows up on earth and it's this massive
final battle the other half of this is
that while these leaders of the various
Lantern cores are able to face off
against some of these threats at the end
of the day the number of black Lantern's
there are almost overwhelming there's
millions of them and so in response to
this ganthet one of the guardians of the
universe one of the guys who helped to
create the Green Lantern Court comes
along and basically says I'm making
myself a Green Lantern not only that
because of the fact that almost all the
rains are basically built on the very
nature of the Lantern rings themselves a
Green Lantern rings and this is of how
their design how their program what this
means is that each member each each one
of these guys can basically create a
deputy of sorts the ring can duplicate
itself and then go out and find a host
what this does is it allows for a
temporary bolstering of numbers we end
up seeing these rings race off and pick
some amazing house the first one that
gets picked is Lex Luthor and it's the
coolest thing ever because while all
this is going on Lex Luthor is met with
an orange ring of avarice he becomes an
orange lantern scarecrow becomes a
yellow lantern Barry Allen a Blue
Lantern so on and so forth it's one of
the coolest things ever
we get to see characters as men as
various members of the Lantern Corps
that we would normally never see in this
particular scenario and that's why it's
so interesting is because blackest night
was designed to be this massive story
that was huge in scope but one of the
first things that people started asking
when we saw these introductions of these
different Lantern cores is well what
would happen if Superman became like a
Red Lantern or what would happen if like
Wonder Woman became like a star sapphire
that's that's the way this plays out is
be
it's basically giving fans their heart's
desires here's what you want to see
characters who would never have a
Lantern ring suddenly get one and then
what would they be like now of course in
the middle of all this we transition
basically out to what's left of the
Green Lantern Corps to Kyle Rayner to
ceramic not to the daughter of Sinestro
all these different things now remember
in the last video we talked about how
Kyle Rayner had basically died how Kyle
Rayner as a Green Lantern was believed
to have been dead it took the combined
efforts of one of the star sapphires the
lantern and tribe of love to grab
ceramic not to the daughter of Sinestro
who Kyle Rayner I guess who was in love
with Kyle Rayner to basically tether
that life force and bring back Kyle
Rayner who effectively sort of
resurrected the problem with this is
that in that moment when Kyle Rayner was
dead Guy Gardner of Earth lost it now
here's a funny thing man I love Guy
Gardner Guy Gardner fans are a
relatively small me it's not the biggest
fan base out there but by god they are
hardcore they lie they love Guy Gardner
and understandably so because Guy
Gardner is like the guy you want in your
corner when the world's going to pot
when it's all going down if I'm somebody
and I'm like okay Who am I gonna pick to
be my Green Lantern who do I want my
corner Guy Gardner because he will fight
until he dies like he's just he is so
awesome and he's so badass but the guys
are for cop you know basically become a
Green Lantern so like he's a no-nonsense
guy in this scenario when he lost his
mind he was suddenly bonded with a Red
Lantern ring now remember when it comes
to the Red Lanterns you don't get to
choose to become one when you get so
full of rage and so full of wrath the
Red Lantern ring just shows up to you
and says you have great rage in your
heart you belong to the Red Lantern
Corps and just forces itself onto you
but this is important because when a
person becomes a Red Lantern their heart
basically gets replaced by the Red
Lantern ring which means to say the Red
Lantern ring becomes their heart their
blood gets your place with plasma if
Kyle Rayner somebody were to walk up and
just take the Red Lantern ring off of
Guy Gardner it would kill him his heart
would basically cease to exist his body
would shut down and that would be the
end of it and so this is basically a
conflict on two fronts is Kyle Rayner
and cirrhotic not two and the Green
Lantern Corps trying to face off against
the Black Lanterns while at the same
time trying to find a way to bring Guy
Gardner back now none of it really
matters anyway because Guy Gardner is a
Red Lantern is wrecking the Black
Lantern
it is it's do is one of the coolest
things to see because dude the guy the
guy lose
man Livius upcoming action right here
the guy loses his mind on these black on
these black lanterns like they're doing
what they can't but it doesn't matter
man guy you do got garner freak saucers
come come feel that it's one of the
coolest things ever to see his character
freak out like this because he's just a
force of nature
like he's just working through every
last one of these black Lantern's not
enough that he's destroying them in
their entirety and reducing a number by
a huge portion but certainly enough
that the black Lantern's are starting to
get a little concerned now in the middle
of all this were met with the arrival of
Mogo basically this planet that received
a Green Lantern ring now mogul is one of
the most powerful Green Lantern's out
there just because of the fact that he's
able to put out a massive amount of
power because of its size but mojo is
also like this secondary base of
operations because he's a planet should
Oh the home base of the Green Lantern's
of the guardians of the universe should
it ever be destroyed Mogo would become
their base of operations we saw that in
the new 52
but what mogul also says is that in this
moment right now there is a protocol
that was devised by the guardians of the
universe that was given to mojo should
ever become a overrun the idea of mojo
is to implement what's called a purge to
effectively purge those who are
intruding in this instance it's the
black Lantern's and so what Mogo does is
basically increase his own gravitational
pull and then grab all every every
single thing within his immediate
vicinity on on OA and drag it directly
to where he's at and it brings them all
down to the surface of his own planet
what he does is he basically grabs these
black lanterns and starts pulling them
down into his own core which is
superheated like the core of any planet
and then basically just starts atomizing
them so sure I guess their rings are
there but their physical bodies are
destroyed and the Razr useless without a
physical body and so where the day is
one so to speak for a temporary moment
what we end up still having is Guy
Gardner as a Red Lantern and so the
question becomes how do you fix him how
do you fix a guy who's a Red Lantern the
only way to really fix a Red Lantern
quote-unquote is to basically have a
Blue Lantern show up and cleanse their
body of the red impurity and then allow
the the removal of a ring if a blue
lanterns not there there doesn't seem to
be a legit conceivable way in order to
save Guy Gardner but there is okay so we
are we're wrapping up blackest night we
have like this one and there's another
video today and then we're done and
we're gonna be finished with our double
uploads on on blackest night as much as
I love it I kind of want to return to
just doing like green lantern videos
once a week because I think it gets a
little weird over saturating with Green
Lantern's too many Green Lantern videos
drives everybody crazy but anyway so for
those of you guys who were new the long
and short of this is that blackest night
is basically the end times is this idea
that these Black Lantern rings that has
kind of risen out of nowhere and the
result is that they're bonding
themselves to people who are both living
and dead now with those who are living
is basically those who have died and
then they were supposed to move on to
the afterlife but they didn't DC
editorial decided to bring him back but
within the confines of DC story itself
which is to say within the DC Universe
it was this idea that the entity of
death nekron had stepped in and kept
those characters from dying and so at
this moment right now there are two
conflicts taking place the first one is
out in space involving the Green Lantern
Corps and the second is on earth and on
earth it's largely just the superheroes
that are there doing the best they can
to stave off against this conflict it's
members of the Sinestro Corps
I mean Lantern Corps is so on and so
forth it's all the cores on earth trying
to stop the end of all things because
remember if the black Lantern's
basically bond rings to everybody then
the emotional spectrum will effectively
cease to exist all beings everywhere
will feel no emotion whatsoever and the
result is that they will just sort of
Usher in this new era of Darkness the
universe itself will effectively die now
what we covered up to this point was the
idea that the superheroes were just
trying to stave off this eventualities
they were trying to stave off the idea
that everything was gonna die but in the
middle of their attempts to stop the
being necron they're subtly met by the
arrival of the spectre now the spectre
is a character that we haven't really
talked about too often we haven't really
done a whole lot with him when it came
to the spectre as a concept he goes all
the way back to like 1940 I mean he's
one of DCs oldest characters he was
created by Jerry Siegel I think it was
and the whole idea was that the spectre
was designed to be really one of the
earliest components of DC's whole
mythological side which is to say all
their demons and angels and and so on
and so forth but the spectre is the
living embodiment of basically God's
vengeance in the sense that there was a
guy named Jim Corrigan he was shot in
the line of duty instead of dying he
basically became a host for the spectre
and so the spectre basically just
travels
earth in the DC landscape and finds
those individuals who have been judged
by God as basically being condemned to
damnation and then just whisks them away
and that's really about it but the whole
idea with the specter is that in the
early days he was crazy powerful I mean
he was almost reality-warping godly
powerful now when crisis on Infinite
Earths going forward if you know after
the mid-1980s DCD powered him quite a
bit but the whole idea was in the Jim
Corrigan inspector dichotomy reigned
supreme for quite some time but
different writers did different things
with the characters but the whole idea
was that in the post-crisis landscape DC
actually killed off the character of Jim
Corrigan the whole idea here is that
following the death of Jim Corrigan
there was a story called day of judgment
and even then there was some you know
stories that took place in between there
where it was basically the question of
what is DC going to do with the
character of The Spectre what are they
gonna do with the character of Hal
Jordan remember and 93 Hal Jordan
basically became parallax and we'll talk
more about that here in a minute but the
idea was that you know how Jordan
basically became this corruptible guy
and DC was removing him to replace him
with Kyle Rayner and so it made sense to
basically merge you know Hal Jordan and
the spectre together which is where all
that stuff happened but the whole idea
was that there was a sort of bouncing
around that took place with the spectre
concept now in terms of how it exists
now a Hal Jordan and the spectre split
from one another it presented itself as
the same scenario what did they do at
the specter if he doesn't have a host
and so what this did is it introduced a
character by the name of Crispin Allen
and the whole idea was a Crispin Allen
was basically this guy who was a partner
of the character of Renee Montoya
Crispin Allen is basically the new host
for the spectre and is one of those
interesting scenarios because what this
does is it actually leads us into the
concept of parallax because the spectre
is designed to be the living embodiment
of God's vengeance and because the
spectre while he is weaker than he's
historically been is still an incredibly
powerful being what this means is that
none of the heroes on earth can actually
stop this Spectre now in terms of the
fact that Crispin Allen was killed and
then became a host for the for the
spectre this meant that Crispin Allen
could actually become a block Lantern
and that's what we saw over the course
of the blackest night story as we
basically saw a ring bond itself to
Crispin Allen and so what we learned
over the course of blackest night is
that instead of the Black Lantern rings
actually resurrecting the dead instead
what they were doing is they were
bonding themselves to the corpses of
those who died and then basically
duplicating them and so in this end
this black lantern Spectre is not
actually The Spectre instead it's the
ring creating an image of The Spectre
and the way that we know that is because
of the fact that with Hal Jordan
basically sitting down and saying we
cannot defeat the specter on our own
because of the sheer power that he has
he says the only way to do this is to
bring back an entity that I've never
wanted to bring back again what he does
is he brings back parallax but at this
moment right now when Hal Jordan
basically goes back to being parallax
when he returns to being a host for the
parallax entity he's not as powerful as
he was but the goal of him returning to
the role of parallax is not for the
purpose of destroying the spectre it's
for the purpose of bringing the spectre
out when Hal Jordan as parallax begins
fighting the spectre and essentially
tears him open what we end up finding is
that within this black lantern shell is
the actual spectre himself alongside
Crispus Allen
so they're basically being held captive
and their power is being channeled and
used by the Black Lantern ring now
following this defeat our black lantern
specter what is it happening is it's
basically just Hal Jordan being split in
half again because Hal Jordan is still
in there he has an emotional tie to
Carol Ferris Carol Ferris was the love
interest of Hal Jordan for years and
years and years and years and so because
of this it's basically this idea that
the spectre can seize hold of parallax
and pull the entity out of Hal Jordan
but only if somebody is pulling the
other direction and that's why that
works is because it's basically Carol
Ferris who Rabb's onto the Hal Jordan
concept and pulls on him while the
parallax entity is being pulled out and
it means that Hal Jordan goes back to
his normal self the other half of this
is actually the actions of Atrocitus of
the Red Lanterns but one of the things
that Jeff John hits on here is the idea
of the Red Lantern entity and so what
this is going to do is lead into you all
these different entities now we'll cross
that bridge when we get to it but for
right now what this also hits that is
the idea that no one can really escape
the might of a Lantern ring so long as a
being is sentient if a ring can bond to
them they can become part of that core
and in this instance what Atrocitus
actually tries to do is bond the spectre
to the Red Lantern ring but it doesn't
last it lasts maybe for like a panel or
tooth and the reason for this is because
when a Red Lantern ring takes over a
host a certain amount of time has to
pass before that person is completely
converted into a Red Lantern but in the
instance because the specter so powerful
he doesn't fall prey his heart's not
replaced or anything along those lines
but the reason why it's proccess did
this is because Atrocitus is actually
believed that the spectre is basically
the Red Lantern entity that Atrocitus
has been looking for the Red Lantern
equivalent to like parallax and so
because of this the specter simply
responds by saying you can't make me
into a Red Lantern but I've met the
entity that you're looking for and if
you find it it will kill you it's this
idea that Geoff Johns is setting the
stage for this huge expansive revelation
of all these different things that will
come later on down the line with regards
to all these different cores now with
regards to the spectrum self what he
ends up doing is actually trying to take
out necron but this is a major
limitation of the spectre while the
spectre used to be this godly powerful
being back in the 40s in the 50s and 60s
and 70s nowadays he's basically just a
guy that shows up and just whisks the
souls of the Damned off and that's it
that's really all there is to it and
this instance Necron does not have a
soul and so in this instance because of
the fact that Necron does not actually
have a soul for the specter to take the
specter is basically powerless against
him not only this Necron actually whisks
the spectre away what it means is the
right hand of God cannot stop necron now
if the president's chose to step in sure
like that would be the end of it and
necron would be defeated but you know in
this circumstance the story needs to be
told
so aside from pulling in you know one of
those caveats that's really about it
things wrap up pretty fast now with
regards to the whole idea of Guy Gardner
and the Green Lantern Corps one of the
things that we had talked about in the
last video was that the Green Lantern
Corps itself at least what was left of
their number due to the fact that so
many of them were being killed by black
Lantern's and then being converted into
black Lantern's themselves Kyle Rayner
one of the more popular Green Lantern's
was believed to have been killed and in
his rage Guy Gardner had lost his mind
and then was bonded with a Red Lantern
ring and what we're seeing right now is
this transitionary period where Guy
Gardner is basically at a point where if
the ring is pulled off he will
essentially die the various Green
Lantern's are basically trying to find a
way to bring Kai Gardner down and then
basically cure him because remember one
person becomes a Red Lantern they're
just mindless rage and so the Green
Lantern planet Mogo is actually able to
offer some measure of a reprieve and
it's really cool the way this happens
and what mogul basically does is force
a guy gardener to basically have this
inner fight with himself which is to say
the green lantern part of himself that
recalls all the great memories the love
interests he's had and different things
like that
and the red lantern part of himself that
really does kind of feeds on all the
horrible experiences that he's had the
idea here is to actually offer some
measure of a distraction to allow the
green lanterns to muster their number
and then subdue a guy Gardner and so
what this does is it allows Mogo the
planet to actually pull a Guy Gardner
down inside of him and then begin
releasing all these different leeches
now this is the second way in which a
person can be cured when it comes to red
lantern rage in truth while this does
purge a lot of the red lantern energy
out of them one of the things that's
immediately made clear is that Guy
Gardner is not completely cured of the
red lantern energy if his ring was
removed he would die and so the only way
to really bring him back the only way to
restore it some measure of normalcy is
to bring him to a blue lantern because
blue lanterns are the ones that
basically go through this sort of
cleansing process and they're the only
way in which a person who is a red
lantern can safely have their ring
removed and then go back to being part
of whatever core they were before so
again this basically brings the Green
Lantern Corps directly to earth where
this final battle will take place and so
again transitioning back to earth proper
while all these different heroes are
basically trying to defeat necron at the
end of the day they're not able to
defeat a being of such intense power the
arrival of Guy Gardner and the other
Green Lantern's the fact that the blue
lanterns are here all the different
cores have united under the idea of
trying to defeat necron but none of them
can do it because he's just such an
astronomically powerful being not only
that we end up getting an explanation as
to why it was that necron stepped in the
way and kept all these different
superheroes from dying over the course
of their lives
the reason for this is because necron
has been seeking something out and the
only way he can attain it is to actually
kill one of the guardians of the
universe and then used their blood in a
ritual of sorts and then in turn wake up
something called the life entity and so
when it comes to the to the life entity
itself it's essentially this idea that
this is kind of a representation of
where life originated and that's one of
the big revelations that comes out of
this is because it was believed that the
guardians of the universe the mountains
were the first race in the universe but
what this reveals to us is
life did not start with the Malthusians
it started on earth the Malthusians
covered that up they basically took the
life entity buried it in the core of the
earth and then wrote it out of history
in order to one ensure that people would
believe that they were the original
source of life in the universe the first
race to pop up and to to maintain their
power and to protect the life entity to
keep an event like this from actually
happening it is designed to show the
guardians of the universe as beings who
were full of hubris who believe that
they legitimately have the right to
decide how the universe should progress
and so it basically would have brought
the entire foundation of what it is that
made the guardians of the universe as
they are crashing down around them and
people would have just lost trust in
them entirely not to mention the Green
Lantern Corps probably would have
vacated but more so than that
the life entity is the representation of
life in the DC Universe and if somebody
harnesses that power they would become
God and that's the fear that the
guardians of the universe have that if
people knew the life entity exists it
would be like this great gold rush for
the power of the life entity it could
potentially even uh sure in this massive
Universal Civil War of people who were
coveting all this power and whoever came
out on top no matter what their
intentions were they would be virtually
unstoppable and so in this instance were
Hal Jordan rationalizes this is okay
well we have to seize the seize the
power of the life entity in order to
basically destroy necron in the Black
Lantern Corps thousand Estero steps in
and Thal Sinestro says no you had
parallax I get the life entity and so
what we end up having here is basically
the rise of the first white lantern in
the form of thousand estro who seizes
the power of the life entity itself
okay so picking up with the conclusion
of blackest night we're finally here
we're finally done something like ten
videos later were finally finished with
blackest night gothis stories lengthy
brightest day is even longer but the
cool thing is that writer's state does
not have nearly as many interesting
tie-ins so that'll actually be done and
probably around like anywhere between
four to six videos and will take
anywhere near as long so uh when it
comes to blackest night again we're
basically dealing with the end of
everything we're dealing with the
conclusion of the event which is to say
this final battle between the Black
Lanterns as well as all the other
Lantern cores and the super heroes who
were trying to stop them now something I
want to point out here because over the
course of the blackest night series I've
been looking through the comments that
you guys have been leaving with like a
lot of questions and different things
like that and one of the most common
questions that I've seen is if Necron is
like the living embodiment of death in
the Green Lantern universe when it comes
to the emotional spectrum then how does
DC consolidate that and how do they make
that work with like death of the endless
and different things along those lines
so here's would be a little bit of a
little bit of explanation here when it
comes to comic books you will oftentimes
have entities that will represent the
same thing multiple entities will
represent the same thing sometimes
coming book publishers make an effort to
consolidate that and make it make sense
and sometimes they don't when it comes
to the Green Lantern line of stories and
DC Comics when it first launched it was
very much in line with a lot of the DC
stuff but the more popular it became the
more DC began to adopt the mindset if it
works don't fix it and so what they
ended up doing was basically telling
Geoff Johns do what you want to do as
long as it fits in with the continuity
of stories we don't really care what
goes on and so what ended up happening
is who is creating all these different
entities and things like that
nekron is the living embodiment of death
how that reconciles with like death of
the endless I don't know now the the
continuity sticklers this will drive
them nuts they will go crazy over this
but you just kind of have to roll with
it you have to go with it it's the
nature of comics it does make things a
little bit confusing and it does make
things a little strange but continuing
on with this whole scenario because of
the fact that all the roads of these
different characters are leading to
earth which is to say die Gardner and
Kyle Rayner and the Green Lantern Corps
you know basically traveling to earth
because that's where the brunt of the
conflict of blackest night is taking
place with Jon Stewart of the Green
Lantern's traveling to earth because
that's where brunt of the conflict is
taking place all these stories begin to
consolidate into one
giant amalgamation of everything going
on in a singular location but keep in
mind when it comes to the the stories
that we've seen so far one of the things
that we found was that there was a black
lantern planet called zhanchi a planet
that have previously been destroyed by
the actions of Jon Stewart of the Green
Lantern's the result is that the planet
itself was made into a black lantern and
then housed all these people that had
died on it when it exploded and they
became black lanterns as well and so
with Jon Stewart showing up basically
making amends with his past mistakes and
then leading zhanchi directly to earth
this meant that this whole planet and
all these black Lantern's on it come
flying back towards Earth now at the
same time keep in mind the idea of the
black Lantern's
attacking members of the different cores
is still there and they all do it in
their own individual way but keep in
mind but whenever we talked about ideas
we're coming book publishers were like
Marvel or DC was testing the waters and
they were bringing characters back and
they were basically doing saw three
boots that's what this is you're
literally learning about this in real
time the whole event of blackest night
is just pick and choose what characters
get to come back and what characters
don't but it also hits at the very
nature of the characters themselves with
Kyle Rayner there was a woman in his
life by the name of Alex duet and Alex
de Wet was really one of the huge really
one of the biggest controversial
characters out there because of the way
in which she died when it comes to DC
there's a character called major force
and major force was a guy who was
created by Kerry Bates and Greg Weissman
I think it was and so the whole idea was
that major force was basically a guy who
was working for something called the
quorum organization I think and this
really coincided with the establishment
of Kyle Rayner being the Green Lantern
the idea of the quorum organization
which was just this really clandestine
corrupt aspect to the US government was
to basically get the power of the Green
Lantern but they could not directly
challenge Kyle Rayner because of how
powerful he was and so the idea was to
demoralize him and have one of two
things happen either he gives up or
they're able to basically just take him
out in a moment of weakness and so what
had happened is that under the direction
of the corm organization major force
killed Alex do it the girlfriend of Kyle
Rayner basically broke every single bone
in her body and then crumpled her in a
refrigerator and it was a massive
controversy when that happened because
it created this archetype that like love
interests always just quote unquote end
up in refrigerators women in
refrigerators kind of a fun fact other
writer one of the writers at the time
Gail Simone actually
launched a website called women in
refrigerators dot-com I think and that's
what that phrase came from but the whole
idea was that it established this
precedent the cow Waner can never find
love every woman he falls in love with
will eventually die but the idea is that
with kyle rayner facing off against the
Black Lanterns
Alex duet comes back as one now remember
the Black Lantern served the purpose of
basically manipulating people forcing
them to feel a wide array of different
emotions and then when their hearts are
completely charged you know consuming
that emotion basically killing them and
then turning him into black Lantern's in
turn and so in this instance what Alex
do it does is actually taught Kyle
Rayner over and over again by giving him
a description of everything that major
force had done when he killed her
because remember all Kyle Waner knew is
he came home and just found her stuffed
in a refrigerator and that was it what
this does is it goes through line by
line in his cest major force broke every
single bone in her body broke her spine
broke her neck the whole nine yards and
then stuffed her in a fridge but by
forcing Kyle Rayner to relive this
massively traumatic moment in his life
the goal of the Black Lanterns is to
turn him is to basically put him in a
moment of weakness kill him take his
heart and then turn him into a Black
Lantern the funny thing about this is
remember he already experienced this at
the hands of Jade another love interest
who had basically died Kyle Rayner had
experienced this emotional manipulation
and so as one of those things were it's
like fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on me and so he's not as
easily manipulated because he sees right
through the guys he's not emotionally
taunted now this is important because
one of the things that I hope you guys
notice over the course of the blackest
night event and even over the course of
everything we've done in Geoff Johns run
is it's building up the character of
Kyle Rayner emotionally psychologically
it's building him up to a guy where he
can basically withstand virtually
anything and that will become
exceedingly important later on down the
line
but again because the fact that this is
everybody you're really trying to deal
with the Black Lanterns and trying to
figure out a way to end the Black
Lanterns coming across their central
power battery the source of all their
energy what we discover is the fate of
the anti-monitor now remember during the
end of Sinestro Corps war when the
anti-monitor was basically revealed to
have been resurrected when the
multiverse came back after Infinite
Crisis when we ended up having this
whole idea that the anti-monitor joined
Sinestro he was more or less kind of the
the harbinger of the core and then
ultimately was defeated by the guardians
of the universe and so on and so forth
the Green Lantern's
is that the anti-monitor was just sort
of whisked away and then suddenly there
was a black lantern central power
battery of course what this ends up
telling us here is the anti-monitor is
basically the source of energy for the
central power battery now of course with
the other lanterns who were here they
all do their best to try to take him out
the problem is that the anti-monitor is
not fully a black lantern and the reason
why that matters is because remember
when a person is full on a black lantern
a massive shock of just white light can
take them out but because the
anti-monitor is not fully a black
lantern yet that's not enough you need
an insane source of energy a massive
amount of energy to be able to destroy
him along with a huge amount of bright
light and so what they end up doing is
they grab the character of dove now dove
is an interesting concept in DC Comics
honestly I don't know that much about
her I know enough to be able to say that
she's one of these characters that is
that's that really exists alongside the
the concept of Hawk and Dove originally
it was it was dawn Hall and it was Hank
Hall I think it was I want to say Hank
Hall was Hawk and Donna Hall was was
dove but I'm not a hundred percent sure
about that but it's basically this idea
that they represent law and order they
represent you know war in chaos I think
Hawk represents war in chaos dove
represents law and order they're
basically two opposing dichotomies that
function in unison and essentially
you're superheroes in a lot of ways in
this story right now dawn the energy
that she puts off in terms of this white
light as far as I'm aware is something
that has not been explained not at the
time of this story's given I don't know
if we ever get an explanation I'm not a
hundred percent sure about that if we do
brightest today would probably be the
place where it happens but the whole
idea is that because she lets off this
massive amount of light energy basically
this this white energy they put her in
like a pod and they shoot her into the
brain of the anti-monitor they literally
shoot him into his head now it's not
enough to destroy him in his entirety
remember the anti-monitor is just this
godly being he can usually always
reconstitute himself but it does offer a
chance for them to grab the anti-monitor
try to pull him out but it doesn't work
he ends up getting yanked back in to the
Black Lantern central power battery and
he continues to be a power source once
more and so again this is really just
John sitting down and saying all right
here are the ways in which to defeat
Necron of the Black Lantern Corps the
anti-monitor is not one of them and so
again this basically brings y'all Guy
Gardner and all those guys directly back
to earth in an attempt to try to take
out you know nekron and
and all the black lanterns and all that
kind of good stuff now again in the last
video we had talked about how we saw the
emergence of the white light entity the
entity of life which is to say
somewhere along the line when the
multiverse came into existence when
everything was created the life entity
came along with it now this is actually
kind of cool because a lot of people
looked at this and they said we'll this
contradicts everything we know about the
origin of the universe actually it
doesn't the origin of the multiverse
stays the same it's still the idea that
there was just this hand that came out
of the beginning of all things and that
hand spawned the creation of the
multiverse and so on and so forth all
this means is that when the multiverse
was new before anything came into
existence when it was basically created
but was just a vacant empty space the
life entity was born and the life entity
what we don't know who made it we don't
know where it came from the life entity
was responsible for the creation of all
life that exists on earth and presumably
out in the universe and so with the
sinestro as the host of the life entity
at the moment following its introduction
of the fact that he seized hold of it
what it does is it gives us the sort of
play-by-play of how everything on earth
unfolded this sense that when the life
entity emerged on earth that it gave
birth to the first single-celled
organisms and then those single-celled
organisms evolved in a multi cell
organisms one of those organisms wanted
to live it wanted to grow it wanted to
continue on and it gave itself the
willpower to do that and in doing so
became the first entity of the emotional
spectrum the ion whale the
representation of willpower in the Green
Lantern mythos in the emotional spectrum
following this there were organisms that
took off from a sea in order to live on
land fearful of their own extinction
that fear gave way to the existence of
parallax we saw things like love which
gave birth to the predator the tration
of the bull based on rage the idea that
something killed something else out of
anger out of malice for the first time
all these different entities are born
from emotion they're born from the idea
that some organism human or otherwise
felt that emotion for the very first
time and when that emotion was felt for
the very first time then it in turn gave
birth to that entity in the emotional
spectrum and so what this means is that
it's basically saying all life in the
universe originated on earth it all
started with Earth and that's where the
emotional spectrum came from
and so with this in mind because of the
fact that the white life is basically
the antithesis to the Black Lantern
Corps meaning it's the only thing that
can actually legitimately destroy the
Black Lanterns in their entirety
Metron panics and impale style Sinestro
now again that's an important thing to
keep in mind when it comes to a being
who is in possession of one of the
entities it doesn't mean their physical
body cannot be harmed they can still be
harmed they can still be taken out the
caveat is the white lanterns because the
white Lantern is the representation of
life a person who is a white Lantern can
never truly die so long as they're in
possession of the white lantern entity
we know this with the case of thousand
Estero because while he is basically
split in half none of the other lanterns
who were analyzing him see any Sigma n
ething to indicate there's been any
actual damage to his body as far as
their rings are concerned looking at the
Sinestro he's just as normal as he ever
was and that's because what the life
entity does is basically heal his
physical form and return him back to
normal that's what we're talking about
with this level of power now Sinestro as
the host for the white Lantern is
basically God it's insane how much power
he has now the other thing to keep in
mind is that just because a being
becomes a host for the entity for it for
any one of the lantern entities doesn't
mean they suddenly know everything about
everything there's a learning curve you
have to learn what the life entity is
capable of you have to learn the limits
of its power and that's why in this
moment thousand Estero doesn't just snap
his fingers and everything goes back to
normal and everything's fixed he doesn't
know the full length of what it is he's
capable of all faul Sinestro knows is
the history of the white Lantern's is
the history of the fact that the white
Lantern's represent life the problem is
that FAL Sinestro is hubris he's full of
arrogance Bal Sinestro being hosts for
the white Lantern he's not doing that
because he believes it's the right thing
to do he's doing that because he sees
himself as the best of all the lanterns
and that's always been the downfall of
Sinestro in every single circumstance
whenever Sinestro gained some extreme
level of power his arrogance was always
his downfall now his first attempt to
take out nekron is actually pretty
successful in the Sin City rips his
heart out and totally destroys it but
keep in mind in the Green Lantern mythos
necron is the living embodiment of death
and he's surrounded by black Lantern's
and so all that is up happening is he
basically just transfers his essence to
another black Lantern and he's reborn
again he's in effect an immutable
indestructible force but only under the
circumstance that his tether is allowed
to remain on earth now the heroes did
not know about this and were not
discovering this until right now
William hand is basically the tether of
mekin remember William Han was a guy who
is basically just obsessed with death
that death was the only thing that
mattered that everything dies and so
because he was so obsessed with it
nekron effectively latched his essence
and established William hand as a tether
and what this means is that so long as
William hand is dead and as a Black
Lantern
nekron will always come back and so the
idea is to basically eliminate William
hand but killing him won't do any good
because he's already dead he's already a
Black Lantern and so the only thing they
can do to remove him from being a tether
of Necron is to actually bring him back
to life
is to essentially resurrect him now
notice this it's a really cool scenario
to unfold here because it's basically
all the hero's coming to grips with
everything I mean for the most part when
you're Barry Allen and you you know
quote-unquote died during crisis on
Infinite Earths and then you came back
you're just kind of like okay cool
that's awesome and when you're Hal
Jordan and you were paralyzed and you
were basically destroyed and then you
came back you're just like oh that's
that's cool whatever and what's been
espoused by necron so far is that each
and every time one of these characters
died he's the one that's stepped in the
way and he's the one that brought them
back but what we're end of what we end
up learning here is this as propaganda
this is nonsense by necron it's him just
running off at the mouth and espousing
things in order to make everyone believe
that he's this you know immutable
indestructible force and he's the
absolute authority on what lives and
what dies in truth that's not the case
the point that Hal Jordan makes here and
one of the things that he comes to the
realization of is sure when they all
were supposed to have died and that
crown basically stood in the way between
them and the afterlife but it doesn't
mean they had to come back it doesn't
mean they had to return from the dead
what it meant is they chose to come back
they chose to go back to being who they
were before now the intricacies behind
this are wide and varying based on the
character at the time you look at these
characters and you see them going and
greeting death in a wide array of
different ways sometimes willingly and
sometimes unwillingly but the goal that
Hal Jordan mace is when they were
presented with the opportunity to come
back to return to life they chose that
and so all neck
it was stand in their way and steer them
a different direction they chose what
direction they went in and so our desire
to live is stronger than our desire to
die ie we have a stronger connection to
life than we do to death and the reason
why that matters is because that creates
a click and what ends up happening is
every single member of the Justice
League every single character who has
died and has come back becomes a white
Lantern now it's a fleeting thing it's
only for a momentary thing they actually
channel it all directly into William
hand and effectively resurrect him
basically get his heart pumping again
and bring him back to life
in doing so it destroys the tether that
Necron has on earth and essentially
sends him flying back but not only that
remember we talked about how blackest
night was a soft reboot that DC would
use the events of blackest night to
basically begin going through and
deciding who would live and who would
die this is that moment when a white
Lantern ring flies through Necron it
effectively destroys his heart and sends
him back to the realm of the unliving
what this does is it basically starts
seeing the resurrection of all these
different things the anti-monitor is
resurrected firestorm and Martian
Manhunter and Jade and like Hawk and
eobard thawne up to Maxwell Lord all
these characters DC just starts bringing
back and that's the point of blackest
night the point of blackest night is for
DC to sit down and say we have an event
where everybody's gonna die we're gonna
do a clean slate everybody's gonna be
killed then we're gonna introduce the
white Lantern's then we're gonna use the
power of the white Lantern's to decide
who basically gets resurrected and who
goes back to being dead when the power
of the Black Lantern rings are destroyed
it's basically a lot of the most popular
characters is DC in a lot of ways
consolidating their entire publication
lineup and reducing the number of Heroes
that they currently have out there and
that's why you end up seeing a lot of
these characters who had previously died
walking around after the events of
blackest night going into brightest day
is because they were all effectively
resurrected and so once everything comes
to an end you know once it's all said
and done the question becomes well then
what happened to the white light it's
apparently is gone you know nobody's in
possession of it anymore and so what
geoff johns does is he teases the events
of brightest day by basically saying
there's a white Lantern power battery
out there now there's basically going to
be a white Lantern core but how that
number progresses what happens to them
is anybody's guess and we'll have to
wait till blanket or two brightest day
to find out without being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
it make sure you guys hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob port if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah we are finished with
blackest night we are done the blackest
night double uploads are done because I
was getting kind of burned down on
blackest night to be honest with you
guys but uh but yeah we are finished so
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]